d'avoir répondu à l'invitation que je
vous adresser pour cette commission j'ai
bien conscience que c'était pas très
pratique pour nombre de nos collègues de
provinces parce que généralement ils
arrivent le mardi or le mardi était
férié donc beaucoup nous disent qu'ils
sont encore dans les transports quel que
soit leur matinale à laquelle ils ont dû
partir donc moi je ne suis pas
totalement frais ayant pris 15 heures de
vol hier grâce à Monsieur Poutine pour
rentrer de la Corée au moment de partir
les Coréens du Nord ont commencé à
bombarder la Corée du Sud enfin c'était
vraiment assez spectaculaire bien nous
avons l'immense bonheur et la grande
chance nous sommes mieux que BFM puisque
nous recevons le la grande voie de BFM
sont heureux en colonel de vous entendre
ce matin ce n'est pas la première fois
du reste qu'on vous accueille vous êtes
déjà venu devant notre commission
notamment quand on sait quand on
s'interrogeait sur l'évolution de
l'opération barkhane je rappelle
brièvement le brillantissime état de vos
services est ancienne sous-officier puis
offic des troubles de marine vous avez
servi au 21e RIMa et au deuxième Rima
que la Commission a eu l'occasion de
visiter et l'an passé vous avez été
déployé plusieurs fois à l'étranger
notamment deux fois Sarajevo
vous êtes également docteur en histoire
enseignant en histoire militaire vous
êtes l'auteur de plusieurs ouvrages
reconnus le dernier étant le temps des
guépards qui retrace et analyse les 60
dernières années d'opération militaires
de la France je vous recommande la
lecture de ce livre qui est tout à fait
passionnant et donc mon colonel c'est
donc à tous ces titres que nous avons
souhaité vous entendre ce matin sur un
sujet qui retient évidemment tout à fait
notre attention c'est les leçons qu'il
va convenir de tirer de la guerre du
crâne
cette guerre est évidemment loin d'être
achevée et il faut aborder tous ces
sujets avec toute la prudence nécessaire
mais c'est bien pour ça que moi j'ai
souhaité faire appel à vous parce que
parmi tous les commentateurs qui
jacassent sur le sujet il y en a qui
savent et qui travaillent vous faites
vous êtes de ceux-là celles et ceux qui
suivent qui vous suivent sur les réseaux
sauf comment vous faites mais c'est
important quand même de comprendre ce
qui est en train de se passer donc la
guerre est loin d'être achevée mais nous
on se trouve confrontés très rapidement
à l'examen de la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire et pour ne rien
vous cacher immédiatement après vous
nous aurons une discussion élargi entre
nous tous sur la revue stratégique qui
nous est proposé dans un délai du reste
assez assez court et donc on doit
évidemment prendre en compte les
caractéristiques de ce conflit de haute
intensité sur le sol européen qui va de
notre point de vue certainement
redessiner les équilibres géopolitiques
alors on connaît je vous propose de
présenter ce que sont selon vous déjà
les premiers enseignements que l'on peut
tirer de ces 9 mois de guerre en plus
des enseignements généraux qui vous
apparaissent ce sera intéressant de
savoir quelles conséquence devrait selon
vous étirer en France évidemment au vu
de la situation actuelle de nos armées
que vous connaissez aussi
excessivement bien notre commission vous
le savez quand elle s'inquiète depuis
plusieurs années du niveau de nos
munitions on semble avoir découvert
cette affaire mais ça ne date pas d'hier
alors il est sûr que en temps de paix on
pouvait pas trop reprocher à des
gouvernements dépenser des milliards
pour des munitions qu'on était censé ne
pas utiliser malheureusement nous sommes
maintenant confrontés à des situations
un peu différentes de la même manière
que nous nous inquiétons de
l'impossibilité d'atteindre les normes
d'entraînement ou de MCO qui sont
régulièrement fixés nous avons également
une très vif préoccupation sur le retard
accumuler en matière de drone c'est un
sujet sur lequel on avait
on n'a pas été d'une grande lucidité à
l'époque et maintenant on s'aperçoit que
nous prenons beaucoup de retard et puis
aussi sur les difficultés de notre
défenseur solaire de notre espace aérien
et je vous entends souvent dire que
combien le
dégâts qui a subi l'Ukraine y compris
dans les premières semaines ça a été par
les arcs par les arcs c'est arrivé et
donc ça nous conduit à nous poser la
question et nous comment est-on défendu
et c'est là où les c'est là où les
difficultés commencent même si encore
une fois ce que nous avons est de
qualité mais on peut pas dire que on
l'est peut-être en suffisance pour
protéger notre espace aérien enfin il
nous apparaît que cette guerre en
Ukraine toi nous permet de porter un
regard nouveau sur les aspects
logistiques et de soutien des opérations
parce que là aussi on voit bien que chez
troupes russes la logistique a été
assez particulièrement défaillante et
puis évidemment et peut-être
commencerez-vous par nous livrer votre
analyse sur la situation actuelle sur le
terrain on comprend que la pression
Ukraine UK poursuit sur la poche de
Carson mais les éléments que l'on a sont
assez modestes il y a finalement pas
tant de journalistes que ça qui sont sur
le terrain pour décrire ce qu'il voit
donc est-ce que selon vous les
Ukrainiens peuvent espérer reprendre
cette ville prochainement et dans quel
état ce qui serait à nouveau échec de ce
qui serait un nouvel échec de de Poutine
puisque c'était un des un des secteurs
géographiques qui avait été rattaché à
la Russie est-ce que vous pensez que la
campagne russe de destruction des
insrastructures civiles en particulier
centrale électrique est un sens sur le
plan militaire évidemment ça touche
beaucoup les populations civiles pour
essayer de les déstabiliser les civils
ukrainien s'apprêtent à vivre un hiver
extrêmement difficile mais ils sont pour
l'instant disposés encore de très
grandes forces morales et ce qu'ils vont
avoir les ressources militaires pour
poursuivre la libération de leur
territoire voilà je vous propose de
lancer tout de suite cette cet échange
avec un propos d'une quinzaine de
minutes puis après on aura sûrement un
jeu de questions de réponse de la part
de nos collègues sachant
qu'effectivement à la suite nous avons
un débat assez important sur la revue
stratégique qui est dire va s'inspirer
directement de vos propos alors donc
vous êtes tout à fait dans l'actualité
merci infiniment de nous faire l'honneur
de venir vous êtes une voix qui est
écoutée respectée et donc je pense que
c'est un honneur pour la pour la
commission je rappelle du reste que
cette
cette audition est captée et diffusée
sur les sites internet du Sénat mon
colonel vous avez la parole
oui merci de votre invitation c'est
toujours un plaisir un honneur d'être
devant vous alors je
vais commencer par des considérations
peut-être assez générale avant de
revenir sur la situation particulière en
Ukraine
les armées françaises changent de
mission première de priorité mission
prioritaire tous les 10 à 30 ans depuis
1815 je m'étais amusé calculer tous ces
changements et
récemment enfin j'expliquais c'est la
conclusion de mon livre que vous avez
fait le plaisir de citer que nous étions
actuellement rentré depuis quelques
années dans une situation stratégique
nouvelle période stratégique où la
mission première des armées serait la
confrontation tout en continuant à
lutter contre les organisations ça
l'affojihadiste notre mission première
serait effectivement cette confrontation
ce que j'appelle la confrontation par
référence à la confrontation Bornéo
entre le Royaume-Uni et l'Indonésie de
1963 à 1966 est une situation des
puissances politiques s'affrontent de
toutes les manières possibles et
imaginables
des sanctions des embargos des boycottes
des sabotages
de jeux d'influence des jeux
diplomatiques etc etc la seule limite
étant quelques règlements rôles quand
même mais surtout l'imagination et
l'autre est en train de majeure de cette
situation c'est que on ne s'affront pas
ouvertement et à grande échelle il n'y a
pas de combat on ne verse pas le sang à
grande échelle et de manière ouverte on
peut s'affronter je citer la
confrontation de Bornéo britannique et
indonésien se sont affrontés
militairement mais tout en le niant de
part et d'autre malgré les centaines de
morts que ces combats ont pu faire
c'est une situation que on appelle
à mon sens de manière totalement
impropre et confuse de la guerre est
bonne
emploi jamais cette expression parce que
justement au dessus de cette de cette
situation de confrontation il y a la
guerre donc la confrontation c'est la
situation dans laquelle nous trouvons
actuellement entre la Russie et les pays
occidentaux voilà nous sommes en
confrontation nous faisons pas la guerre
la guerre c'est exactement la même chose
on peut continuer à se faire mal de
toutes les manières possibles mais en
plus il y a des combats il y a des
combats violents et de grandes
importance donc c'est évidemment ce qui
est en train de se passer entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine et puis il y a un
échelon encore au dessus qui est la
guerre nucléaire qui se rappelle
son existence et qui est au-dessus de
cette conflit ou de la guerre
conventionnel est une sorte de trou noir
dont l'importance est elle est en
influence et telle que on a les plus
grand réticence à s'en approcher
évidemment ça influence tous les étages
inférieurs et donc le conflit en Ukraine
au moins aura le mérite aura eu le
mérite de remettre en lumière ces
différents niveaux d'affrontement que
l'on avait un peu oublié et qui ont leur
logique propre et si on nous avions été
cohérent avec ce contexte encore une
fois c'est la situation de confrontation
il a réussi n'aurait pas commencé avec
en février
verrouillé 2022 c'était déjà le cas
depuis plusieurs années évidemment elle
a pris un tour particulièrement aigu
depuis février
2022 mais il fallait effectivement s'y
attendre il fallait s'y préparer à cette
confrontation avait la Russie
éventuellement d'autres puissances on a
eu quelques déboires aussi par exemple
avec la Turquie mais on peut imaginer
les mêmes choses avec avec la Chine et
si nous avions donc été cohérent nous
aurions remodeler un peu notre système
de force afin de le rendre capable à
faire peur à influer
intimider un adversaire influer ce
influencer sa politique lui faire peur
en capacité on aurait modeler pour être
capable par exemple d'occuper des
terrains très vite une bonne exemple de
confrontation encore une fois c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau la France se
trouve en situation confrontation en
1903 contre le Brésil vous avez trouvé
en situation de confrontation contre
l'Iran dans un à 80 contre la Syrie le
même période qui était allié de l'Iran
mais aussi contre la Libye et c'est
d'ailleurs en bon exemple de
confrontation plus ou moins enfin plutôt
réussie par situation confrontation
plutôt réussie donc exemple de de
capacité qui aurait été extrêmement
utiles cette capacité à occuper une
position
pendant la guerre froide on parlait de
stratégie de piétons imprudence
c'est-à-dire se mettre au milieu du
terrain d'un seul coup sans en
surprenant tout le monde et puis bloquer
toute la situation parce qu'on est là
quand les Russes ont
occupé la la Crimée en quelques jours
voilà on dans la situation de stratégie
de piéton imprudent et vous en placez
tout le monde devant le fait à conflit
nous avons fait la même chose nous au
Tchad c'est l'opération mentale en 1983
quand ils ont été capables de déployer
très vite une force au milieu du Tchad
et de placer la libido de moins en
situation du tout ou rien à ce que vous
faites si vous allez plus loin c'est la
guerre est-ce que vous voulez vraiment
faire la guerre avec nous donc capacité
aussi à être capable de enfin capacité à
combattre dans des espaces un peu floues
un peu gris avec des soldats fantômes
avec des capacités d'action clandestine
les capacités d'action discrètes avec
nos forces
nos forces clandestines ne forces
peut-être aussi l'emploi de société
privée qui présente énormément davantage
pour agir comme des effets chinois agir
sans agir agir sans être là
mais agir quand même
vous avez capacités et aussi
éventuellement à combattre à plus grande
échelle s'il le faut
parce que cette situation de
confrontation entre puissance et
notamment entre puissance nucléaire
n'exclut pas la possibilité de conflits
majeurs que ce soit dans les espaces un
peu vides qui ne sont pas sous parapluie
nucléaire la France a participé à la
guerre de Corée dans les années 50 dans
ce contexte là ou alors parce que et j'y
reviens le contexte peut changer
stratégique mondiale peut changer
brutalement
je rappelle combien nous avons été pris
de cours en 1990 lorsque d'un seul coup
j'étais encore sous les drapeaux à ce
moment-là on dit bah voilà il faut aller
faire la guerre à l'Irak un cas qui
était absolument pas prévu
et que nous avions absolument pas
anticipé être capable de faire une
guerre à un état lointain très loin de
nos frontières et avec des forces
importantes et donc il faut là aussi
être capable de
remonter en puissance très vite et à cet
égard là je rentre un peu plus dans le
la situation
vraiment de la situation en l'Ukraine
premier enseignement à tirer de cette de
cette guerre en Ukraine c'est bien la
nécessité d'être capable de remonter en
puissance très vite ce qui a sauvé
l'Ukraine c'est qu'elle disposait de
réserves de réserviste afin de réserve
de réserve matériel
c'est à dire qu'il avait des stocks
alors ça c'était l'héritage de l'armée
soviétique de l'immense armée soviétique
donc les Ukrainiens disposaient au moins
de stocks de matériel relativement
importants l'armée russe aussi bien sûr
mais l'Ukraine a fait l'effort de
constituer des réserves humaines et
c'est réserves humaines qui ont
véritablement sauvé la situation ils ont
permis très rapidement de compléter les
forces d'actives de manière individuelle
ils ont permis de constituer des unités
de combat des brigades quatre brigades
complètes qui ont été constituées de
réserviste elles ont permis surtout
d'encadrer de structurer ce qu'on
appelait des brigades territoriales plus
de 25 brigades territoriales qui ont été
constitués à partir de réserviste puis
de volontaires
et ainsi que des unités de garde
nationale et de sur le direction du
ministère de l'Intérieur et donc c'est
un système avec des vrais réservistes
bien formés qui
qui ont d'expérience militaire qui a été
tous fait tous fait des passages par
exemple sur la ligne de front du
non-basse dans les années qu'on
précédait la guerre et qui ont permis de
voilà l'armée se termine ukrainienne de
remonter en puissance de constituer même
le cadre je dirais de cette montée futur
elle a été capable une crainette et
capable de mobiliser ses ressources et
de les faire monter après en capacité
chose que les Russes sentaient
incapables de faire et ça c'est une
véritable
certaines façons c'est une véritable
surprise effectivement les Russes
disposent et c'est en fait c'est le seul
atout qu'ils ont matériellement
disposent de stocks de matériel
considérable encore une fois hérité de
l'armée soviétique donc ils ont des
chars des véhicules blindés ils ont de
tout tas de choses à l'abondance en
stock ils ont des en stock des obus en
stock considérable mais ils n'ont pas
des stocks d'hommes et ça c'est la faune
surprise et c'est principal leur grande
faiblesse
la Russie a lancé cette guerre c'est de
manière assez inédite d'ailleurs
peut-être la première guerre entre état
Grande Guerre majeure entre États
européens ou le pays agresseur ne
n'implique pas la nation ne mobilise
même pas la nation pour mener cette
guerre et la décrit même comme une sorte
d'opération lointaine opération
extérieure mener uniquement par des
soldats professionnels donc maintenant à
l'écart autant que possible la société
russe ce qui est un phénomène encore une
fois inédit et assez extraordinaire du
coup
les Russes ont engagé toute leur armée
professionnelle pratiquement d'un coup
d'emblée en Ukraine sans avoir prévu de
plan B et sans prévoir prévu de capacité
de
renouvellement de reconstitutions de
cette armée
or cette armée était malgré tout
relativement réduite à peu près entre
120000 hommes qui ont russes plus les
armées des républiques séparatistes qui
ont été engagés à peu près 40 000 ont
été ensuite envoyés en renfort mais
c'est une armée qui a été ce qui est
relativement modeste au regard de
l'enjeu de l'enjeu militaire
l'Ukraine fait sensiblement la
superficie de la France et donc il faut
imaginer que
la France de 1940 ait été attaquée
uniquement par les divisions blindées
allemandes voilà vous avez oublié tout
le reste de l'armée allemande et vous
gardez les 10 divisions de Panzer et
voilà c'est avec ça que la Russie a
attaqué attaqué l'Ukraine donc un corps
expéditionnaire relativement réduit et
finalement assez fragile et lorsqu'il
s'est consommé
et particulièrement pendant le premier
mois de la guerre qui a été très
meurtrier pour les forces russes ils ont
été incapables de
[Musique]
reconstituer cette force cette force
l'armée russe n'a cessé de se dégrader
au fur et à mesure de la guerre donc
elle a des capacités ce sont réduites au
fur et à mesure au début de la guerre
ils étaient capables de faire des choses
assez sophistiquées des opérations en
tout cas qui étaient relativement
complexes certaines ont réussi
et puis avec
à partir du mois de mars ils ont été
plus capables que de faire des combats
assez simples violents mais extrêmement
simple très proche de ce qu'on faisait
pendant la Première Guerre mondiale et
puis depuis le mois de juillet ils sont
même plus capables de monter ces
attaques de de grands ampleur donc il y
a une régression permanente de cette
armée russe de ces forces terrestres en
particulier et alors que inversement des
les Ukrainiens eux montaient en
puissance eux ont mobilisé toute la
nation et petit partie ils ont formé des
soldats de vrais soldats grâce à ce
cadre dont disposer initialement et aux
partir du mois de août les courbes se
sont croisées d'une certaine façon et
cette armée ukrainienne est devenue la
première armée d'Europe l'armée la plus
puissante d'Europe incontestablement je
parlais des brigades territoriales au
début qui brigade d'infanterie légère
destiné à tenir le terrain faire du
harcèlement et ces brigades sont
devenues de véritables unités
professionnelles ils ont récupéré de
l'armement beaucoup plus lourd sont
devenus des brigades de manoeuvre et
c'est et ces unités ont permis d'une
certaine façon de doubler la capacité de
l'armée ukrainienne et donc à partir du
mois d'août cette armée ukrainienne a
été à la fois supérieure en nombre
supérieur en nombre de unités de combat
supérieures en qualité tactique de de
ces unités et à partir de là les
excréments ont forcément pris
pris l'initiative
et donc
deuxième
anciennement que je tire c'est seulement
général je tire aussi c'est du côté
russe c'est la difficulté que quand ont
eu les Russes a
comment dire à vouloir se doter d'une
armée comparable capable de rivaliser
avec celle des États-Unis avec le PIB de
l'Italie et
forcément en voulant avoir être au
maximum dans tous les domaines les
Russes ont pas été n'ont jamais été très
bon partout les les
l'armée russe dispose de d'un arsenal
nucléaire absolument pléthorique plus de
6000 têtes nucléaires dans plus de 2000
qui sont opérationnels c'est c'est
colossal pour un budget qui
qui doit représentent en budget réel qui
doit représenter entre deux fois et
trois fois celui de la France sont
obligés de défense réel par le même pas
dit officiel
c'est colossal c'est beaucoup trop en
réalité mais en même temps les Russes
ont fait énormément d'efforts pour
essayer de moderniser en leur flotte
d'autre de leur marine leur flotte de
haute mer en particulier ils ont fait
beaucoup d'efforts pour
moderniser leur aviation dispose d'un
arsenal entier aérien qui est
extrêmement puissant ils ont développé
des catégories des forces spéciales ils
ont fait des des forces légères des
forces aéroportées une armée à part ils
ont consacré également beaucoup
d'efforts et au bout du compte
finalement l'armée qui se bat qui porte
la guerre à 80% c'est c'est l'armée de
terre sont les forces terrestres et ils
restaient 20% du budget pour les forces
terrestres russes qui finalement se sont
retrouvés la force utile je dirais celle
qui combat véritablement
été réduite à la portion par son congrue
et donc
la Russie a voulu se doter d'un modèle
d'armée de riches sans en avoir les
moyens et
au bout du compte
ce modèle s'est trouvé inadapté à la
guerre réelle qu'elle a dû qu'elle a dû
mener
autrement qui est lié au précédent moi
ce qui me frappe aussi c'est c'est le
combat dans le ciel donc on a un peu
évoqué mais
c'est une guerre une nouvelle guerre où
il y a en fait il y a pas d'avion dans
le ciel ou très peu voilà ou
d'hélicoptère enfin d'avion piloté
d'humains dans le ciel
c'est c'est pas complètement nouveau la
guerre entre
l'Arménie et l'Azerbaïdjan il y a deux
ans étaient assez également inédite dans
ce
ce point de vue il n'y a pas d'avion pas
de pas d'hommes dans le ciel mais la
guerre de 2014 et 2015 en Crimée surtout
dans le gambas il faut pas oublier quand
même que dans le bombasse en 2014-2015
il y a eu des combats extrêmement
violents dans laquelle les forces russes
ont été impliqués assez grandes assez
grande échelle mais pareil pas d'avion
pas d'hélicoptère très rapidement peu
pas d'avion pas d'hélicoptère pourquoi
pour fondamentalement deux raisons alors
je précise les Russes utilisent
effectivement leur aviation leur force
d'hélicoptère mais de manière
extrêmement prudente et
au plus près du front en sûreté donc ils
font des sorties ils font des
utilisateurs leurs moyens pour appuyer
les forces terrestres sans avoir la
souplesse de nos moyens à nous sans en
avoir même complètement de tout aussi
tous les moyens et au bout du compte
c'est une force qui est très largement
sous-utilisée alors pourquoi pour deux
raisons fondamentales d'abord parce que
le ciel est devenu trop dangereux pour
un ciel qui est
défendu avec un système de défense
anti-aérien aussi dense que si fort que
celui de l'armée
ukrainienne sur toutes ses couches
devient extrêmement dangereux pour
c'est trop dangereux pour envoyer des
engins à plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'euros et puis avec des humains à
l'intérieur
si si les les Russes utilisaient leur
aviation pour effectuer ce qui sont en
train de faire là des bombardements sur
les villes sur les infrastructures il
suffit de leurs avions ils auraient déjà
perdu probablement plusieurs centaines
d'aéronefs déjà tout en l'utilisant de
manière extrêmement prudente et de
manière documentée donc inférieure les
réalités ils ont perdu une soixantaine
d'avions et une cinquantaine
d'hélicoptères encore une fois c'est
inférieur la réalité mais ce sont des
pertes prouvées ce qui est déjà
considérable il faut imaginer ce que ça
représenterait pour nous si on perdait
autant de autant de d'aéronef
et j'y reviens ils utilisent oui
s'ils utilisaient leur aviation pour
attaquer les villes
sera bien sûr serait détruite ne serait
cassé complètement
donc du coup et c'est le deuxième
élément
on utilise de part et d'autre des moyens
de substitution à
cette aviation pilotée et qui sont sur
fournis évidemment par les drones pas le
drone et missiles c'est-à-dire que
avec des drones maintenant ou des
missiles vous pouvez assurer
pratiquement la quasi-totalité des
missions qui étaient
qui était l'émission des de l'aviation
pilotée vous pouvez faire de la
reconnaissance vous pouvez faire des
frappes vous pouvez
il y a que le transport effectivement
pour l'instant on pourrait pas
transformer transporter d'individus
aux dans le ciel ou noterez au passage
que cette guerre se caractérise aussi
par le fait qu'il y a aucune il y a eu
une opération héliportée par les
portages au tout début de la guerre et
c'est pas bien passé et donc depuis il
n'y a plus il n'y a plus non plus de
d'êtres humains portés dans le ciel pour
aller faire quoi que ce soit donc il y a
des instruments de substitution avec des
drones on pourrait faire désormais plein
de choses et c'est évidemment aux
économisez des vies et économiser aussi
un peu d'argent du coup cette campagne
aérienne de frappe
et qui est mené par les Russes
actuellement contre les infrastructures
civiles
ukrainienne c'est
la première campagne de frappe qui est
menée uniquement par des robots ou des
missiles depuis la campagne des V1 V2
menés par les Allemands en 44-45 et
sensiblement d'ailleurs pour les mêmes
raisons parce que il faut faire quelque
chose et on sait pas quoi faire ça c'est
possible bon on peut frapper sur les
villes donc on sait c'est un côté un peu
un peu vain un peu
voilà il faut la seule carte dont on
dispose pour pour agir d'un peu de
manière offensive donc on l'utilise et
donc
cette oui cette cet usage du ciel d'une
certaine façon
est assez c'est troublant et quand même
indique une tendance profondeur c'est
pas une surprise ça fait des années
qu'on explique que
on a on n'aura pas forcément
éternellement la suprématie dans le ciel
que on arrivera dans les endroits qui
sont beaucoup plus contestés qu'on l'a
connu or on a quand même un petit peu
fondé notre modèle aussi sur cette idée
d'une d'une de la supériorité aérienne
voire de la suprématie que l'on a eu
pendant des années et quand je dis nous
c'est quand même essentiellement les
États-Unis et qui nous ont permis ou qui
ont en tout cas justifié par exemple et
on revient ce qu'on disait en trop
polymère que
de
réduire la portion congrue par exemple
notre artillerie ou notre artérior
solaire considérant que bon c'était plus
très utile puisque artillerie solaire
c'est pas utile qu'on a la domination du
ciel bon et artillerie même sol c'est
pas forcément très utile puisque du ciel
on peut frapper précisément puissamment
et de loin donc pourquoi pourquoi avoir
des systèmes redondants donc du coup on
se trouve dans une situation un peu un
peu compliqué et donc en résumé
il y a avant de répondre à vos questions
c'est ce qu'un indique en tout cas notre
ce conflit c'est bien et son contexte
c'est que
notre modèle de finalement de force
n'est pas forcément adapté justement à
cette nouvelle situation cette nouvelle
air stratégique cette nouvelle situation
si nous
nous disposons pas de réserve voilà il
faut me dire très peu on a sacrifie nos
réserves réserve matériel on réserve
d'êtres humains si nous faisions le même
effort que les Américains si les
Américains sont sont très présents dans
cette guerre 600 six fournis 70% de
l'aide militaire à l'Ukraine c'est parce
que ils se sont donné les moyens de
d'être de le faire tout simplement je
rappelle que si nous faisions le même
effort que les Américains en termes de
défense en termes de pourcentage de PIB
notre budget de défense serait de 92
milliards d'euros si on faisait la même
fort que les Américains tout simplement
toute proportion gardée alors évidemment
ça serait pas du tout dans la même
dimension
et nos capacités seraient pas les mêmes
mais les Américains consacrent là aussi
des ressources très importantes pour
leur réserve et leur garde nationale si
là aussi si nous faisions le même effort
que les Américains en la matière nous
dépenserons toute proportions gardées
nous dépenserions
2,8 milliards d'euros chaque année pour
uniquement pour nos réserves évidemment
ça nous
[Musique]
celle de l'opération mentale monta
épervier au Tchad en
puissance 10 je dirais c'est-à-dire
avoir une capacité de projection et de
présence très rapide capacité projection
de force
instantanée voilà d'être capable
d'occuper n'importe quelle position et
puis après de placer notre adversaire du
moment devant le fait accompli en disant
mais voilà maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on
fait
on aurait pu imaginer
si
voilà si on avait été peut-être un peu
plus courageux et quand je dis nous
c'est le monde occidental de déployer
des forces extrêmement rapidement par
exemple en Ukraine au moment de avant la
guerre quoi avant la crise on aurait
placé les virus sont très forts pour ça
et cette stratégie être si nous avions
placé tout de suite en quelques jours
des brigades à Kiev ou le Landa
frontière en plaçant les Russes ce que
nous avons fait un petit peu le long de
la frontière
de l'ordre de l'Est Roumanie ou dans les
Pays-Bas plus tard mais
si nous l'avions fait ça directement à
l'Ukraine nous aurions placé devant les
les Russes situations compliquée
du tout ou rien voilà est-ce que vous
pénétrez en Ukraine ou c'est vous qui
déclencherez la guerre contre contre
nous avec toutes les conséquences que
que cela peut avoir bon c'est une
hypothèse après c'est une décision
évidemment politique mais il faut encore
faut-il avoir cette capacité cette
instrument que nous n'avons plus
forcément donc cette capacité de
projection rapide cette capacité
de sinon de projection de force de
projection d'aide notre capable de
d'encadrer d'aider n'importe quel pays
alliés
face à notre adversaire nous devons être
capable de d'affronter de combattre je
reviens dans les espaces gris beaucoup
plus quand le capable de le faire
actuellement et nous devons aussi
repenser un petit peu notre rapport au
ciel d'une certaine façon et évidemment
ça ça renvoie tout notre retard que nous
aurons accumulé en matière de d'aviation
de ronique pour dire simplement les
Ukrainiens sont désormais l'armée la
plus équipée en drone au monde et il
dépasse de très loin tous dont nous
pouvons disposerons aussi au passage que
nous sommes quand même fait dépasser
dans ce domaine alors que nous avons
toutes les compétences possibles
imaginables en matière aéronautique sont
dépassés par la Turquie
dans dans ce domaine donc je ferme la
parenthèse et donc voilà il faut
repenser notre outil dans le dans ce
sens là
être capable de faire une guerre au loin
d'autres intensité très vite et puis
être capable de de combattre en
périphérie de la guerre
d'agir en tout cas en périphérie de la
guerre beaucoup plus efficacement qu'on
le fait et se rappeler que tout ça
changera probablement dans une quinzaine
d'années et que le contexte changera
probablement à nouveau et c'est quelque
chose il faudra là aussi repenser
complètement ce modèle alors que on a
des situations des procédures des
équipements qui sont qui sont conçus en
réalité pour la longue durée voilà je
rappelle que l'avion Rafale a été
premier vol date de 1988 était conçu
pour combattre les avions soviétiques
au-dessus de l'Allemagne de l'Ouest de
la publicité générale allemande et que
il sera toujours là en 2040 en 2060
alors que le tout le contexte
stratégique aura changé pour
probablement troisième fois et qu'on
sait pas du tout comment il sera utilisé
nous nos équipements quand nous lançons
des équipements savoir comment on va les
utiliser au bout de quelques dizaines
d'années relèvent de la voyance beaucoup
plus que de l'anticipation stratégique
voilà je m'arrête là
et
sur la situation militaire
actuellement si vous voyez la carte les
Ukrainiens je les dis tout à l'heure on
ça ressemble voilà pour moi historien
historien la Première Guerre mondiale ça
ressemble beaucoup à une situation de
1918 où les les
Ukrainiens sont la place des alliés à
partir de l'été 1918 dispose d'une
supériorité incontestable de la Force
terrestre et à partir de là Martel le
front et là on s'est opérations jusqu'à
essayer d'ébranler en tout cas le tout
le dispositif russe qui lui est devenu
extrêmement passif et donc les les
Ukrainiens ont lancé deux grandes
batailles de grandes opérations une d'un
côté de Carson donc complètement au sud
et l'autre complètement dans le Nord et
conserve peut-être la possibilité de
lancer une troisième bataille c'est ça
c'est parti de mes interrogations quand
je compte le nombre brigade il m'en
manque
donc elles sont quelque part et
peut-être que si voilà c'est les
Ukrainiens lancés une offensive du côté
au centre de de ce front en direction de
ménithopole ça pourrait avoir des
conséquences considérables toujours
est-il actuellement
les
les la bataille de Carson donc qui
attire l'attention
donc voyez cette tête de pont qui est
sur la rive droite du fleuve Dieppe dans
la région de Kerson or c'est c'est
important plus fort représenté la taille
d'un département français donc là vous
avez les Russes incontestablement sur
certainement sur décision politique
parce que militairement c'est plus
délicat ont décidé de tenir à tout prix
cette cette région autour de la ville de
Kerson tu arrives droites il y a à peu
près 20000 soldats russes sur la rive
gauche et à peu près autant et
vous avez là à peu près un quart de tout
de toutes les forces russes qui sont
concentrées autour de Carson ce qui
montre bien qu'il s'agit d'une priorité
incontestable pour eux
ils tiennent la position ils tiennent la
zone parce que c'est c'est une zone qui
est plate c'est laquelle ils sont
installés depuis des mois ils ont
installé ils ont mis pratiquement leur
meilleur troupes dans dans cette région
tous les villages sont fortifiés c'est
comme ces plats tout est visible du ciel
et toutes les préparatifs d'attaques
sont visibles ils peuvent être frappés
par l'artillerie etc donc vous avez ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est le
combat extrêmement difficile pour pour
les Ukrainiens mais une progresse petit
à petit en deux mois ils ont réduit
cette poche par deux et actuellement les
Russes sont en situation où
ils ont rien capable pour impossible
pour eux de reprendre l'offensive mais
en gros soit ils tiennent ils tiennent
cette tête de pont le plus longtemps
possible en espérant que avec la
mobilisation à partir de l'arrivée de
l'hiver puis les effets de la
mobilisation ils pourront peut-être
reprendre le dessus un peu plus tard bon
c'est peu probable malgré tout deuxième
possibilité pour eux c'est de se replier
plus ou moins de manière plus ou moins
organisée complètement de l'autre côté
du ça je pense que c'est les militaires
qui demanderaient ça parce que pour
éviter de se retrouver piégé mais la
troisième hypothèse c'est que voilà ils
vont certainement se replier préparer
une bataille de
urbaine de grande ampleur dans la ville
de Carson ils vont essayer d'en faire
une sorte de Stalingrad sur le Nièvre
incontestablement et voilà tout indique
qu'il se prépare et que tout le monde en
tout cas anticipe cette cette bataille
les services craignent parler d'une
bataille d'encarson pour le mois de
novembre je trouve ça peut-être un peu
optimiste mais en tout cas oui
tout le monde anticipe et puis donc il a
bataille au nord qui après des succès
spectaculaires dans le mois de septembre
marque un peu le pas enfin l'offensive
ukrainienne marque un peu le pas mais là
aussi on n'est pas à l'abri
d'accélération les opérations militaires
se sont pas des choses très linéaires
donc les rues les Ukrainiens
s'approchent
d'un point clé qui s'appelle ce bateau V
qui est un autre communication dans le
Nord à peu près là où se trouve la
de l'explosion
600 parts de ce de ce point clé cela
peut avoir des conséquences fortes
également ils peuvent aller beaucoup
plus loin dans cette éventuellement dans
cette province de louance qui est toute
la province d'or de louansque peut peut
tomber entre leurs mains mais toujours
est-il que dans tous les cas de figure
c'est
on peut pas concevoir
la reconquête complète des de tous les
territoires conquis par les Russes y
compris la Crimée avant
avant l'an prochain quoi c'est rien ne
change par ailleurs or les chemins de la
guerre les choses changent souvent quand
même et donc on laisse un processus
malgré tout qui est relativement long et
qui est voilà militairement qui est en
tout cas qui est annoncé pour de
nombreux mois je l'ai dit il y a une
croisement des courbes une certaine
façon allaiter en faveur de l'Ukraine
en termes militaire comme comment
politique les courbes se croisent
rarement deux fois et donc pour
l'instant oui les Ukrainiens ont
l'initiative et donc à partir du moment
où ils ont l'initiative militaire bah il
est pas question pour eux de d'arrêter
de négocier tant qu'il y a une temps qui
je veux dire tant qu'il gagne il joue
c'est un peu un peu trivial pour quand
il s'agit d'affaires d'affaires ou
ou le jeu concerne la vie et la mort
mais voilà ils sont on fait la guerre
lorsqu'il y a un espoir on continue à
combattre on continue à faire des
sacrifices lorsqu'il y a l'espoir
d'obtenir quelque chose on arrête de le
faire lorsqu'il y a plus d'espoir du
tout c'est ça la paix en fait lorsque au
moins un deux adversaires a cessé
d'avoir de l'espoir pourquoi que ce soit
et puis demande grâce voilà actuellement
les deux adversaires ont toujours de
l'espoir de pouvoir l'emporter de
pouvoir obtenir au moins obtenir quelque
chose à court terme et donc il continue
il est probable que ça continuera
au moins jusqu'à l'an prochain
et sur l'option nucléaire
alors comment dire
alors oui on en parle évidemment
beaucoup c'est revenu sur le devant de
la scène
mais en réalité ce que je constate moi
c'est que finalement les Russes ce sont
d'une grande orthodoxie en la matière
donc oui rappelle qui dispose de l'arme
nucléaire très fréquemment mais on
notera d'ailleurs que la première
déclaration généralement suivie d'une
deuxième quelqu'un d'autre qui disait
qui dira que oui certes nous avons
l'arme nucléaire mais
cette arme ne peut être utilisée que
pour protéger l'existence de la Russie
bon c'est très proche de notre manière
de voir afin de notre doctrine en la
matière donc on est très clairement sur
une doctrine de dissuasion visant à
protéger les intérêts vitaux bon
premier élément donc on commence ces
intérêts existentiels ça c'est
évidemment la vraie la question il
dirait tout ça est-ce que la Crimée peut
être considérée comme
on va dire quelque chose d'existentiel
pour pour la Russie bon c'est
très discutable à mon sens
et puis surtout
alors
on parle d'armes nucléaire tactique
stratégique etc bon ça en réalité ça a
pas beaucoup de sens que bon ça a aucun
sens les armes nucléaires tactiques on a
cessé de d'appeler
on a cessé d'utiliser le terme
arnucléaire tactique dans les années 70
y compris en France
stratégique oui voilà le Pluton était
initialement une arme nucléaire tactique
donc qui dit tactique ça veut dire que
sa décision d'emploi est
décentralisée au niveau de généraux qui
sur au champ de bataille décide de
l'utiliser comme une grosse artillerie
quoi c'est ça c'était comme ça
d'ailleurs que les Américains envisagé
les premières armes à qui jusqu'à ce
qu'on s'aperçoit que
d'abord militairement ça avait pas
beaucoup de sens c'était bon et c'était
très compliqué à mettre en oeuvre ça
avait plein d'influences tout à fait
négatives
et puis surtout c'est que était on
pouvait pas distinguer véritablement
les choses quoi et il y a le nucléaire
où il y a pas le nucléaire voilà c'est
et qui quel que soit la puissance
utilisée en réalité peu importe que
cette arme fasse 10 kg ou face 100 kg
neuralité voilà vous avez utilisé l'arme
nucléaire c'est ça qui est
qui est vraiment important orme
nucléaire c'est une arme utilisez l'arme
nucléaire c'est se mettre en premier
c'est se mettre au bon des nations très
clairement donc la Russie utilise l'arme
nucléaire pour essayer d'intimider alors
c'est aussi pourquoi faire d'ailleurs
pour
intimider essayer de briser la volonté
ukrainienne
pas du tout évident que même que cela
réussisse j'aurais plutôt tendance à
penser l'inverse mais surtout il y a un
prix politique qui est connu vous allez
vous mettre au bon des nations un pays
comme la Chine qui est très sensible sur
un sujet
ne tolérera jamais que la Russie utilise
l'arme nucléaire il n'est pas évident
d'ailleurs même à l'intérieur de la
société russe à l'intérieur des cercles
de pouvoir
on tolère cette cette situation
extrêmement dangereuse
d'autant plus que elle suscitera
forcément une réaction
occidentale on peut pas tolérer qu'un
pays utilise l'arme nucléaire en premier
que cet emploi soit banalisé sinon c'est
la porte ouverte à
des catastrophes en réalité et donc et
par ailleurs on fait quand je dis on les
États-Unis essentiellement ont les
moyens matériels de de frapper de
manière conventionnelle punir de manière
conventionnelle c'est ce premier emploi
donc ce serait une entrée en guerre des
pays occidentaux mais une entrée en
guerre qui peut être brève d'ailleurs
qui peut être un coup un coup de semence
en rien dans la situation
arrière avec des dégâts considérables
qui sont portés à l'armée russe et donc
tout ça pour dire que globalement je ne
crois pas beaucoup à cet emploi il
s'attend cet arme est employé dans le
cadre de la confrontation contre
des fins d'intimidation très clairement
mais son emploi réel
je ne crois pas ça probable on peut pas
l'exclure complètement mais je crois pas
ça du tout probable
allez quelques questions pour que vous
pourrez pour lesquels vous pourrez
répondre collectivement François Bonnot
merci président merci mon colonel pour
votre brillante exposé je voulais vous
poser une question
sur la capacité russe à reconstituer en
interne et en externe sont potentiel
sans potentiel militaire alors
effectivement on parle beaucoup d'Iran
aujourd'hui mais peut-être la Corée et
d'autres pays enfin vous allez donner
des indications je vous remercie
d'accord
merci
Paul Duranton
merci monsieur le Président merci
colonel donc pour continuer sur l'armée
russe donc quel indicateur l'historien
que vous êtes et le spécialiste en un
indice des conflits petit établir pour
déterminer qualifier et mesurer le moral
des troupes donc le moral de l'armée
russe dépend-il plus du facteur terrain
ou du facteur information et contre
informations et une autre question sur
le groupe Wagner qui sévit en Ukraine et
en parallèle de l'armée officielle russe
donc elle prend de plus en plus
d'importance sur les terrains sur le
terrain et dans les médias donc
pensez-vous que son chef pourrait
devenir un danger pour Vladimir Poutine
je vous remercie
c'est mon colonel c'était une fois de
plus très intéressant moi je lui ai
beaucoup d'attention de votre blog et
j'ai quelques petites suivre le blog
si vous voulez apprendre vous en saurez
vous avez beaucoup parlé de guerre de
Tintensité qu'on a théorisé mais quand
on sait pas forcément donner les moyens
d'assumer notamment sur le fait qu'il
fallait gagner la guerre avant la guerre
et sur le fait qu'il fallait montrer à
nos ennemis qu'ils ont été en capacité
de leur répondre et de les dissuader en
tout cas nous attaquer c'est un peu le
modèle d'armée qu'on a voulu mettre en
place on se rend compte aujourd'hui
malheureusement on va parler tout à
l'heure de la revue stratégique il y a
pas vraiment de rétexte de ce qui se
passe en Ukraine actuellement et c'est
bien dommage mais moi j'aurais deux
petites questions vous avez parlé et
vous disiez vous avez dit qu'il fallait
être capable d'occuper une position être
capable de combattre dans un espace flou
gris clandestin est-ce que vous est-ce
que vous pensez qu'on peut faire le
rapport avec ce qui s'est passé ce qui
se passe encore malheureusement au Mali
ou on l'a laissé Wagner arriver sans
brancher sans bouger alors qu'on aurait
parfaitement eu les moyens sans doute de
les mettre dehors de le rencontrer un
petit peu qu'on était capable d'exister
aussi est-ce que vous pensez que ça
aurait changé un petit peu la vision de
Poutine de ce qui aurait pu se passer en
Ukraine est-ce que vous pensez que le
départ des Américains d'Afghanistan a
été aussi une des conséquences a été
aussi une des causes pardon de
l'intervention russe en Ukraine et puis
une petite question rapide sur Smith
vous avez vous parler dans votre blog à
un moment donné de la au moins on parle
de comment
de la de l'action autour de carcoff de
d'un de cinq brigades blindées qui sont
passés inaperçus de par les Russes
alors qu'ils ont des moyens assez
considérables d'informations comment on
peut expliquer ce genre de choses plus
ça ça m'a intéressé ça ça
m'intéresserait parce que j'ai eu le
blog mais j'avais pas la réponse merci
et Isabelle Raymond pavéro
colonel au cours des dernières années on
a vu les puissances militaires de tes
équipements qui sont de plus en plus
sophistiqués mais ce conflit militaire
de la Russie contre l'Ukraine
démontre qu'il ne faut surtout pas
négliger les batailles terrestres qui
sont caractérisées par l'usage entre
autres de matériel beaucoup plus
classique
l'ex-ministre d'ailleurs des armées
madame parler avait elle-même déclaré
qu'il nous faudrait s'interroger sur le
juste équilibre entre la très haute
technologie et des équipements un peu
plus rustiques il ne faut évidemment pas
renoncer à la haute technologie mais
c'est une question dosage alors dans le
contexte actuel de contrainte de stock
d'armes que nous connaissons quelles
leçons tirez-vous de ce constat merci
c'est Isabelle Joël guerriot
merci président merci pour votre
brillante intervention j'aurais quelques
questions on est à 9 jours de fêter la
commémoration donc de la Première Guerre
mondiale on retrouve ici cette espèce de
schéma avec une un front qui sépare donc
de belligérant
ma question c'est on sait que en 14-18
on a eu près de 20 millions de personnes
qui ont été tuées autant sur les civils
que chez les militaires une guerre en
train de forcément des morts des deux
côtés on parle beaucoup de les
militaires on parle pas beaucoup des
civils on sait aussi que ça entraîne
beaucoup de blessés puisque sur 20
millions il y a autant à peu près 20
millions aussi de blessés donc je
voudrais vous poser ces deux questions à
savoir qu'en est-il pour les blessés
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a des
structures ou des moyens de les aider de
faire en sorte de est-ce qu'il y a du
rapatriement de blessés comment on
traite cette question des personnes qui
sont qui se trouvent donc
sur le champ de bataille et avec des
blessures graves comment ça se comment
ça se passe pour eux et puis pour la
population civile on sait que la
population civile dans le dombases pour
une part d'entraide et d'été plutôt
prorus qu'en est-il aujourd'hui est-ce
que ce sont ces gens-là qui sont restés
ou est-ce qu'on a des exactions sur les
civils du côté du Dombas ou est-ce que
sont des gens qui finalement considèrent
que la situation
celle qu'on peut
ils se sentent plutôt libéré qu'autre
chose j'en sais rien en fait quelle est
la situation des civils aujourd'hui et
des blessés merci il reste en parlant de
statistiques est-ce qu'on est-ce que
vous avez des estimations sur le nombre
de morts le soldats Russie vous répondra
après mais Russie Ukraine tous les
chiffres circulent c'est toujours c'est
extrêmement difficile de savoir
exactement ce qu'il en est
on a des des chiffres on a des indices
par en réalité par les destructions de
de matériel de véhicule ça on a c'est
beaucoup plus facilement documentable
notamment un site source ouverte
néerlandais qui s'appelle oryx qui
comptabilise tous les véhicules détruits
par toutes les photos les images les
fait un point extrêmement précis de tout
ce qui est documentaire en termes de de
matériel et à partir de là oui ça nous
donne un indice quand même de la
violence des combats et des pertes
possibles
donc pour moi
les Russes actuellement doivent avoir
perdu à peu près 80 000 hommes
tu es blessé prisonnier etc
non 80000 tout compris tout compris tout
compris tout compris doit être aux
alentours de
entre 20 et 30 000 morts probablement
certainement dans cet ordre de grandeur
ce qui est considérable
et c'est un élément c'est un élément
fondamental à partir d'un certain taux
de perte une armée ne progresse plus à
ce commence à se dissoudre se décompose
vous pouvez plus capitaliser vous avez
des unités qui se qui perdent leur
cohésion vous pouvez plus apprendre vous
pouvez plus c'est une raison pour
laquelle cette armée russe se dégrade au
fur et à mesure parce qu'elle a un taux
de perte qui est colossol
qu'elle ne peut pas absorber elle ne
peut pas absorber et au passage ce top
perte quasiment un tiers des pertes
probablement russes ont eu lieu dans le
premier mois de la guerre
l'offensive autour de Kiev en
particulier
qui était présenté par les prorus comme
étant l'heure comme étant que en fait
c'est une catastrophe
c'est une catastrophe pour pour la
Russie
l'armée russe quasiment cassé
dans ce premier mois de guerre et
notamment autour de Kiev ça n'est jamais
véritablement remise côté ukrainien on
pense que les pertes sont quand même
sensiblement inférieures
à priori donc c'est là aussi c'est
encore plus difficile de savoir
finalement la globalement moins
d'informations sur les Ukrainiens que
sur les Russes et
mais elles doivent être de l'ordre de
40000 ou 60 50000 pertes également cette
différence près que l'armée crânienne
n'est plus volumineuse et que elle était
capable elle plus de
d'accepter ces pertes d'une certaine
absorbée des accepter et ça n'a pas
cassé sa dynamique je veux dire de
monter en puissance alors que c'était le
cas
[Musique]
merci président merci mon colonel pour
tous ces informations et pour vos
réflexions
il semblerait que ce qui est nouveau
dans cette dans cette guerre depuis le
mois de février ce sont les nouveaux
moyens de communication dans le domaine
du renseignement notamment par voie
spatiale il semblerait que les
renseignements américains étaient
absolument déterminants notamment
donnant Ukrainiens les informations
qu'il fallait donner pour cibler et
précisément la localisation des états
majeurs russes
et avec la possibilité ensuite de les
toucher et du coup du fait que les
Russes n'avaient plus de centre de
commandement ou d'hommes pour commander
est-ce que c'est cela qui a été
déterminant pour pour la suite parce
qu'on remplace pas les chefs
d'état-major ou les responsables de haut
niveau comme ça du jour au lendemain le
fait qu'aujourd'hui les Russes semblent
s'attaquer plus tôt aussi villes par un
intermédiaire de l'électricité ou de
l'eau ne donne-t-il pas à penser que en
fait l'armée aujourd'hui russe est
devenu extrêmement faible ce qui fait
qu'elle s'attaque de manière privilégiée
au civils ukrainien vous avez dit mon
colonel dans votre début de votre
intervention qu'on devait changer de
stratégie en quelque sorte un peu tous
les disques 20 ou 30 ans est-ce que la
stratégie qui est la nôtre depuis toute
cette période à savoir la dissuasion
nucléaire
mais j'aurais tendance à dire que la
dissuasion nucléaire était nécessaire
mais ce qui est aujourd'hui la
démonstration est faite qu'elle n'est
pas suffisante et du coup à partir du
moment la loi de programmation militaire
semble s'orienter vers 2 à 3 milliards
par an sur l'inflation ça fait du
milliards est-ce que vous pensez que si
véritablement à la hauteur des enjeux
que nous traversons aujourd'hui merci
Olivier Cadic
c'est monsieur le Président will lors de
l'invasion en Ukraine beaucoup de
d'observations de terrain m'avait confié
qu'ils étaient surpris par la vétusté
des équipements militaires russes
utilisés ils imaginaient que l'armement
russe moderne serait réservé pour une
attaque envisagée ensuite plutôt vers la
Lituanie ou la Pologne est-ce que vous
pensez que l'armée russe dispose
effectivement d'équipement plus modernes
en réserve qui n'aurait pas été utilisé
pour une attaque éventuellement
ultérieure est-ce que les drones
iraniens utilisés par les Russes sont
les mêmes que ceux qui ont pu voir
frapper les intérêts Ibériens ou
saoudien dans la péninsule
la stratégie de l'escalade apparemment
qui est celle des Russes puisqu'il
développent un discours de victimisation
pour justifier leur agression donc là
ils ont un des menaces contre le
Royaume-Uni on entend parler de ça
est-ce que vous pensez vraiment qu'ils
soient en capacité d'engager un nouveau
front pour développer cet escalade
Olivier on avance Ludovic est
merci président mon colonel je tenais à
vous remercier pour la qualité des
propos que vous avez pu tenir dans un
dans un contexte de désinformation on a
peut-être pas on a peut-être pas assez
parlé un contexte de désinformation
assez inégalé jusqu'à présent je crois
que on sait tout sur ce conflit et on ne
sait rien jusqu'à tout dernièrement le
pont Crimée la quantité exactement de ce
qui s'est passé les dégâts qui ont pu
avoir lieu on entend un petit peu tout
et n'importe quoi donc je crois que nos
amis russes et c'est un chemise de le
dire Mani il a des informations comme
comme peu de pays le font c'est des
informations et les permise notamment
grâce à la multiplication d'un certain
nombre de l'appareils numériques sur le
front mais aussi dans les dans les deux
pays par rapport à aux enseignements que
vous avez donné à tirer de cette guerre
est-ce que pour vous le le côté
numérique les cyberattaques que l'on
peut peut-être inclure dans le dans
l'expression guerre hybride que vous
n'appréciez pas particulièrement mais
qui est encore une fois à mon avis à
tous son sens quand on sait que
l'Ukraine est régulièrement attaqué en
attaque cyber depuis 2014 les hôpitaux
les écoles les organismes est-ce que
pour vous la résilience de l'Ukraine est
à prendre en compte comme enseignement
notamment dans la manière de se remettre
d'une attaque numérique et informatique
et la deuxième question si on le
permettez c'est au regard de la
justement de la part que représente les
nouvelles technologies aujourd'hui dans
nos armées et au regard aussi des
attaques d'un nouveau genre auquel nous
avons pu assister je pense à Cassat
notamment les satellites on n'a pas pris
de l'accouche spatiale nos russes nos
amis sont encore une fois j'arrête pas
de dire aux amérus mais ils sont pas
tant à Mixa c'est l'expression sa
manière le détournement de certains
appareils satellites est-ce que pour
vous il faut changer de paradigme mais
se dire que l'avenir de nos armées ne
passera pas forcément par une armée
au totalement au bout du progrès mais
peut-être par une armée plus résiliante
ou la mécanique privée sur le numérique
merci merci on continue avec Rachid
temal
merci Président je m'associe à
remercierment de mes différents
collègues colonel je vois trois
questions rapides la première c'est vous
avez pris comme comme image l'histoire
des courbes qui se croisent et puis sur
la question de je veux dire une armée
russe passive en expliquant si je tire
le train un peu c'est que on connaît un
peu la fin de l'histoire ou en tout cas
on sent pouvoir le connaître ma question
c'est donc Poutine jusqu'où et jusqu'à
quand pourra-t-il tenir et dans quelles
conditions donc si vous avez vous comme
ça des premières réflexions parce que si
au bout d'un moment ça va comment être
compliqué même pour son armée la
deuxième c'est que dans votre réflexion
sur notre armée d'aujourd'hui voire de
demain il y a deux absents donc pourquoi
et quels sont peut-être développer un
peu la question de l'OTAN
et la question des allures européens et
donc du fameux pilier ou pas défense
européenne donc et la troisième question
qui est on va dire un peu plus
provocatrice c'est si vous étiez demain
ministre des Armées ce que serait votre
première mesure
puis
Jacques le nez oui merci monsieur le
Président en colonel vous avez nous avez
expliqué que les troupes criniennes
étaient en état de supériorité je
voudrais savoir quelle erreur
stratégique
doivent absolument éviter les Ukrainiens
pour ne pas rester dans cette dynamique
de victoire et est-ce que les formations
des
Occidentaux peuvent permettre de les
éviter
merci Jacques Alain joyeux
merci monsieur le Président heureux de
retrouver après un covid sérieux tout va
bien merci
colonel d'abord une remarque
c'est très difficile au fond de savoir
ce qui se passe parce que vous faites
des supputations vous donnez des
chiffres on ne sait rien on dit que les
courbes se croisent qu'elles ne se
recroiseront plus je pense que c'est
très difficile d'avoir cette cette
affirmation dans vos propos on sent
comment dire
pardon je vais peut-être traduire
quelque chose qui est qui est faux dans
votre esprit mais quand on vous entend
on a l'impression que pour les Russes
c'est mort quoi après c'est qu'une
question de temps l'Ukraine va gagner
les courbes se sont croisées et on
reviendra pas en arrière c'est qu'une
question de temps bon est-ce que c'est
est-ce qu'il y a des éléments pour
pouvoir autant appuyer cette ce que l'on
sent chez vous comme comme conviction ça
c'est mais c'est lié d'ailleurs au
manque d'informations précises parce que
au moment de du numérique et de
l'information en continu au fond on a
aucune image on a on une preuve qui qui
vraiment sérieux ce qui qui montre
ce qui ce qui peut se passer là-bas donc
pour moi je reprends ce qui vient d'être
dit par notre collègue on ne sait pas
grand-chose au fond alors que c'est tout
à côté de chez nous donc ça c'est ma
c'est ce que je ressens personnellement
et là-dessus vous avez vous me
convainquez pas sur sur ce que vous ce
que vous nous ce que vous nous
transmettez en fait comme comme
certitude qui semble être la vôtre et
puis après une question toute bête
si vous aviez en face de vous ce qui est
d'ailleurs le cas quelqu'un qui est pas
convaincu
de de la légitimité qu'on a à faire la
guerre à la Russie on est en
confrontation on n'est pas en guerre on
est en confrontation mais si vous aviez
à convaincre quelqu'un qui se demande ce
qu'on fait là-bas
pourquoi
par rapport à l'avenir de notre pays par
rapport à l'avenir de l'Europe pourquoi
c'est quoi qu'est-ce qui fait que
vraiment la France
dans cette guerre
est légitime et les dans la défense de
ses intérêts dans la défense des
intérêts de de l'Europe et voilà je
voudrais comprendre vraiment parce que
j'ai l'impression que personne nous a
vraiment expliqué pas plus ce chef de
l'État personne ne nous a vraiment
expliqué qu'elle était l'intérêt
stratégique majeur de la France de
l'intérêt des jeunes générations d'être
là-bas puis juste pour le pour un petit
code ici quand vous avez dit il faudrait
il faudrait renforcer reconstituer nos
forces pour pouvoir se projeter à un
moment donné ce qu'on a pu capable de
faire on s'est projeté en Afrique on
avait des accords de défense on s'est
projeté on a fait des choses formidables
en Afrique mais l'Ukraine
on n'est pas vous avez dit pour se
projeter pour aller défendre un allié
mais on n'est pas allié des Ukrainiens
jusqu'à preuve du contraire qu'on
reconstitue nos forces pour défendre la
nation en cas d'agression et qu'on
puisse défendre l'intégrité de notre
territoire oui mais reconstituer des
forces pour éventuellement ce projeter
en Ukraine même le président baiden a
dit dès le début du conflit il y aura
pas un seul américain sur le sol à
ukrainien même lui il a dit donc soit
j'ai mal compris vos propos et pardon
faire un peu le la contradiction mais
tout en vous remerciant pour la qualité
de vos propos comme l'ont fait nos
collègues je reste un peu dubitatif puis
vraiment je voudrais être convaincu
qu'il faut y aller quoi
c'est une bonne question car elle se
pose pour certains Gisèle Jourda merci
président merci colonel de tous les
éléments que vous avez portés à notre
connaissance moi je souhaiterais dans ma
question revenir sur de fortes
interrogations par rapport à la
sécurisation des couloirs donc des
corridors maritimes puisque nous avons
là donc les effets de cette guerre qui
se traduisent par la rupture de l'apport
et de l'envoi de céréales et part donc
une crise donc que j'appelle moi une
guerre alimentaire qui est un effet
secondaire important et je souhaitais
vraiment avoir votre point de vue
là-dessus parce que je trouve assez
surprenant comme mettre en place ces
corridors nous avons on voit bien le
rôle de l'Europe je pense notamment à la
déclaration il y a peu de temps donc sur
tout ce qui est la fac les effets de la
parc mais moi je vous sens qu'on est
totalement impuissant là dedans et que
c'est quand même
en effet dévastateur donc aujourd'hui
normalement tout est donc d'après le
centre de coordination conjointe donc
chargé de de l'accord tout serait rompu
si on peut avoir des éléments par
rapport à ça parce que ça préoccupe nos
concitoyens tout autant
on peut pas faire de gradation dans les
dans les questions mais c'est quand même
un effet que je trouve à prendre en
compte de manière profonde
merci Gisèle enfin Hugues souris
merci président mon colonel nous le
savons la LPM aura une considération
particulière pour la réserve vous avez
mentionné la faiblesse de la réserve
française et vous avez insisté sur le
différentiel qui existait entre les
réserves et la réserve russe et Ukraine
ukrainienne ce qui met aujourd'hui
l'Ukraine en position favorable par la
par la Russie au delà du sol nombre de
réservistes quels sont selon vous les
clés de la mobilisation
merci et puis peut-être une dernière
question à l'historien
qu'est-ce qui selon vous motive
véritablement monsieur Poutine de se
livrer à une affaire pareille quand on
regarde sur la carte que ça représente
voilà quand même un dirigeant qui va
mettre son pays au banc des nations
pendant 30 ans peut-être plus alors tout
le monde est rappelle évidemment la
restitution de l'empire soviétique
l'humiliation de
1991 etc mais selon vous qu'est-ce qui
explique fondamentalement de mettre
autant d'intérêt d'une grande nation la
Russie n'est pas n'est pas une petite
affaire pour le don de base dont on
apprenait
dans secondaire que c'était un bassin
industriel mais ça ne représentait pas
quelque chose d'essentiel allez répondez
nous à tout ça
bien alors je vais essayer de faire ça
dans l'ordre sur Oui Oui je vais essayer
la reconstitution des maths enfin
reconstitution matérielle
essentiellement que vous évoquez
en fait en termes de d'équipement la
Russie est plutôt abondamment pourvu les
équipements critiques qui
pourraient lui manquer ce sont
actuellement ce sont plutôt les missiles
on a beaucoup d'interrogations par
exemple sur la capacité de la Russie à
maintenir cette campagne de frappe sur
la longue durée ça leur coûte
accessoirement très cher on peut pas
ils ont peut-être lancé qu'elle est
entre 1500 et depuis le début de la
guerre entre 1500 et 2000 missiles à
plusieurs millions de d'euros pièce
pouvoir plusieurs au moins une dizaines
de millions de d'euros pour certains
donc ça c'est un effort considérable ils
ont accessoirement dilapidé de leur
atout stratégique cette capacité de de
frappe de missiles conventionnelle dont
tous peuvent porter l'arme nucléaire par
exemple
pas d'abord c'est
les drones ont énormément d'avantages
mais ils ont pour l'instant encore en
défaut c'est que la charge utile qui
peuvent porter relativement faibles et
donc les chaînes 136 par exemple qui
sont utilisés par les Russes ce sont des
obus qui sont lancés à très grande
distance en réalité donc ça fait
c'est c'est très éprouvant c'est très
stressant ça peut faire des dégâts et
des pertes mais ça n'a rien à voir avec
la puissance d'un missile donc c'est pas
un substitut
de frappe de domicile mais l'Iran
disposent de
capacités de missile balistique
importante avec des missiles d'ailleurs
qui sont parfois plus performants que
ceux dont disposent les Russes et si
l'Iran fournissait la Russie en missile
balistique alors c'est pas évident parce
que ça c'est une fille aussi pour l'Iran
se privée dans la toux stratégique
quand Israël ça pourrait avoir de fortes
en de conséquence ça pourrait en tout
cas permettre à la Russie de prolonger
cette campagne aérienne avec toutes les
conséquences que ça peut avoir sur sur
la population
ukrainienne donc pour l'instant on sait
pas c'est on l'envisage c'est en cours
la Corée du Nord peut sensiblement faire
la même chose avec des moyens plus plus
vêtus plus réduits pour le reste des
inconnues matériels c'était
la quantité d'obus
dont disposer les Russes
leur atout principal doit tout principal
de l'armée c'est leur artillerie voilà
on a dit que l'armée russe était
finalement c'était une grosse artillerie
qui est rouler et puis avec quelques
éléments périphériques autour mais et
donc c'est à cet artillerie russe
consomme énormément d'obus
énormément de munitions et là aussi on
ne sait pas trop
ceux qui ceux qui n'en est de leur stock
de d'obus sachant qu'ils ont pas
forcément de grandes capacités à enfin
en tout cas leur production ne
compensent pas ce qui détruisent
aussi oui bien sûr parce que beaucoup de
pays ont des matériels exo éthiques la
Corée du Nord éventuellement pourrait
la biologie déjà aide c'est à dire que
plus exactement la Russie pie une
certaine façon les équipements
récupèrent un certain nombre
d'équipements à la Biélorussie donc
c'est matériellement la Russie encore
encore beaucoup de beaucoup de réserves
matériel anciens
moi je t'ai frappé de voir
comment dire j'avais l'impression que
l'armée russe qui attaquait l'Ukraine
c'était la même que ce contre laquelle
je m'entraînais au début des années 80
avec le scénario d'une invasion de
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest c'est les mêmes
c'est exactement les mêmes c'est les
mêmes équipements c'est sensiblement les
mêmes structures les mêmes la même
organisation etc au passage à l'époque
des années 80 on imaginait pas une seule
seconde que la guerre en Allemagne
puisse durer
puisse durer des mois donc tu es sur des
scénarios de quelques jours quelques
semaines grand maximum d'affrontements
on se disait bon de toute façon ce sera
trop violent on peut pas aller au-delà
et donc on était taillés au passage en
conséquence notamment dans le stock de
munitions etc et là une des surprises de
ce conflit c'est quand même d'avoir un
conflit très violent et qui dure qui
dure aussi longtemps ce qui montre que
de part et d'autre ben on avait
effectivement au moins on en avait
suffisamment de stock de munitions de
matériel pour permettre de durer et a
priori ça peut ça peut encore le faire
assez longtemps vous évoquez madame le
moral le moral russe
des servi un peu ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que une armée c'est
une
groupe de soldats ça fonctionne ça
militaire mais très particulier dans la
mesure où on va voir au-delà de au
devant de la mort de la mort de donner
de la mort reçue c'est quand même très
particulier ça demande des hommes des
individus particuliers ou quoi former
pour pénétrer dans ces
dans ces dans ces bulles de violence et
donc ça suppose d'avoir enfin il y a
deux facteurs il y a le premier facteur
c'est il faut quand même un peu se
sentir obligé obligé d'y aller parce que
voilà il faut il faut de bonnes raisons
on va dire pour le faire pour défendre
défendre la patrie c'est une bonne
raison pour
parce que on fait partie d'une unité
prestigieuse qui nous oblige à un
certain comportement parce que on est
entouré d'amis qu'on veut pas de
camarades qu'on veut pas abandonner ou
on ne faut pas paraître leur regard sur
nous nous importe ici on ne veut pas
paraître comme l'âge donc il faut un
certain nombre de raisons qui nous
oblige à aller au combat aller au devant
de la mort et puis ensuite il faut être
deuxième élément il faut être confiant
il faut être confiant dans ses capacités
à le faire c'est capacités techniques
tactiques les équipements qu'on a
l'entraînement que la forme qu'on a reçu
la confiance dans ses chefs la confiance
dans ses camarades etc c'est une
alchimie assez complexe qui fait que on
va au combat et on s'y comporte à peu
près correctement efficacement mais
problème de de l'armée russe c'est que
quand lorsque vous commencez à subir
énormément de pertes que vous commencez
à subir des défaites
ben vous entrez tous ces liens sa
cohésion ce dissout vous voyez arriver
dans vos rangs des gens que vous ne
connaissez plus des nouveaux qui sont
pas forcément bien formés c'est le cas
par exemple des gens des mobilisés qui
sont envoyés un petit peu en vrac donc
la cohésion se dissout vous perdez vos
chefs ou perdez confiance sur
éventuellement dans vos chefs vous
perdez confiance dans la cause vous
demander si
vous subissez des échecs
vous vous demandez ce que ça vaut le
coup de prendre des risques
prendre des risques je veux bien mais à
condition que moi ça servait quelque
chose
si vous êtes reculé en permanence et
ben vous vous êtes tendance à prendre de
moins en moins de risques que vous avez
ainsi une armée qui se dégrade de petit
à petit et qui devient un peu passive au
moins alors qu'il se il n'y a pas de cas
de débandade il n'y a pas de de
mais voilà c'est une armée qui
globalement
moral relativement bas et pour répondre
à certaines questions moi je pense que
et pour prendre un peu à votre question
stratégiquement militairement
les
j'ai dit tout à l'heure si les choses ne
changent pas si on reste dans la
continuité actuellement les choses
changent toujours la guerre donc change
souvent en tout cas et
si les Russes voulaient vraiment
changer un peu le cours de la guerre au
lieu d'envoyer des des fournées de de
cela mal formés directement sur
l'Île-de-France prendrez le temps de
reconstituer une armée solide de
reconstituer des unités de vraies unités
de combat avec une cohésion un
encadrement une fois faible armée russe
c'est son encadrement notamment sur
l'encadrement de sous-officiers voilà
l'armée russe c'est
l'armée russe est une armée un peu
hybride qui qui a voulu copier un peu le
modèle occidental qui a voulu se
professionnaliser complètement tout en
étant relativement volumineuse mais le
problème c'est que n'a jamais eu assez
de volontaires pour ce professionnaliser
complètement et c'est volontaires
eux-mêmes ne restent pas très longtemps
donc il y a jamais eu ce vivier qui
aurait permis de constituer un véritable
corps de sous-officier de ce voilà de
soldats anciens qui sont bons qui
techniquement sont connaissent
parfaitement leur faire qui constitue
l'armature d'une armée ça c'est
virus sont toujours été incapables de
produire encore de sous-officier
solide et tout ça ça contribue ça
contribue à cette affaiblissement donc
on a des soldats qui globalement sont
quand même malgré tout assez résident
c'est ça
mais
la cohésion des unités c'est c'est pour
beaucoup très largement dissoute et
d'ailleurs les le combat lui-même les
attaques ne sont plus portées souvent
que par certaines unités
certaines unités un peu d'élite des
troupes archiistes l'infanterie de
marine les Wagner ou des unités
périphériques le Tchétchène
au passage leurs personnes qui
appartiennent à l'armée de terre russe
quoi c'est des éléments un peu un peu
périphériques il y a des armées privées
qui se sont qui se sont un peu
constitués comme ça en périphérie ça
ressemble un peu
à l'Allemagne troisième âge des armées
chacun produit
on fabrique un peu sa petite armée de
son côté et avec la capacité notamment
parlé de prix gaugine capacité
voilà Wagner c'est devenu une armée à
part
et ses armées d'ailleurs au passage de
coopère assez peu entre elles c'est très
fort un peu leur guerre de leur côté
et les cadirovski de tchétchène ils font
la guerre de leur guerre on peut aussi
de leur côté chacun fait un peu son ces
choses vous avez d'autres armées privées
vous avez la garde nationale qui est
dirigée par un ami de Poutine l'ancien
garde du corps de Poutine zolutov parce
qu'il y a une autre armée à part vous
avez les services d'enseignement on leur
propre force le FSB à sa propre petite
armée le Gru très qui est l'ennemi du
FSB dispose aussi de ses propres forces
vous avez plein de petites armées comme
ça qui qui gravite autour de
de l'armée régulière
je m'éloigne oui mais je parlais
effectivement de ça me permet de parler
de Wagner Wagner au départ l'intérêt de
Wagner c'est normalement c'est d'agir là
où l'armée régulière n'est pas c'est
d'ailleurs en substitut de cette armée
c'est-à-dire là où la Russie veut agir
sans apparaître officiellement et
et dans les endroits qui sont sensibles
politiquesment ou même militairement
d'ailleurs parce que quand des soldats
de Wagner tombent
c'est comptabilisé du part et ça pas
grande importance c'est pas une
importance politique et donc Wagner
servait surtout à ça c'était un
instrument de force russe que dans les
Russes pouvaient éventuellement nier
l'engagement en disant voilà c'est
officiellement en disant c'est une
société privée d'ailleurs officiellement
d'ailleurs la Russie ne reconnaît pas de
société militaire privée et puis
donc c'était un instrument de
d'opération extérieure en particulier en
Afrique ont été engagés dans certains
nombre de terrain ils ont été religions
en Syrie là la nouveauté c'est que cette
armée de mercenaire est utilisée aux
côtés de l'armée régulière et parfois en
substitut de cette armée régulière de
[Musique]
russe et de plus en plus d'ailleurs
parce que apparemment semble-t-il par
exemple les mercenaires de Wagner vont
être retirés du Mali pour pour être
engagé en Ukraine
les
grands historiens arabes parlaient de
des empires comme
disons voilà les en particularités les
empires c'est que en démilitarise la
société on la pacifie pour voilà que ça
pose pas de problème politique
et donc on désarme complètement la
société et mais comme il faut assurer
quand même la défense de l'Empire cette
défense est assurée par des mercenaires
donc on recrute un peu partout mais en
périphérie notamment de l'Empire et là
on a une situation qui ressemble pas à
ça c'est à dire que je reviens à ce que
ce que disait c'est la Russie a engagé
la guerre sans impliquer la société ou
voir là maintenant le plus possible à
distance grande partie parce que
Vladimir Poutine savait que ça pouvait
poser des problèmes d'appliquer la
société il n'a pas confiance dans dans
société et donc il a et c'est une raison
pour laquelle aussi la mobilisation
partiel n'a été retardé autant que
possible parce qu'il savait très bien
que c'était un peu une boîte de Pandore
qui était qui était ouverte dans la
société société russe que ça pouvait
provoquer des mécontentements et que les
moquons mécontentement dans la société
russe
ça amène souvent des changements de
régime la Russie est très très
vulnérable histoire de la Russie montre
que les régimes sont quand même assez
vulnérables aux défaites militaires aux
échecs militaires donc il y avait cette
idée de préserver autant que possible la
société et de confier la guerre à des
volontaires des soldats professionnels
souvent issus d'ailleurs de minorité un
peu périphériques de
de la Russie de mercenaires extérieurs
de Wagner on a recruté des Syriens on a
recruté on recrute maintenant par
exemple des Afghans des gens des forces
spéciales afghane qui ont été formés en
partie par nous d'ailleurs au passage
qui qui se quelques centaines pourront
certainement se retrouver en
Ukraine mais voilà vous avez une sorte
d'armée d'armée périphérique qui est qui
fait la guerre évidemment c'est pas
malheureusement c'est pas enfin pour eux
c'est pas c'est pas suffisant
donc oui Wagner Prigogine Prigogine oui
il fait partie de ces petits seigneurs
de la guerre qui se sont révélés en
périphérie de du pouvoir qui conteste
directement l'armée
et qui on appelle ça la guerre des tours
en Russie c'est le tour du Kremlin
voilà c'est les guerres de clan qui qui
sont autour du régime du régime qui
lui-même pas encore
enfin en tout cas qui qui va si un peu
quand même malgré tout qui on sent qu'il
y a quand même des ça se fissure un peu
il y aura pas de révolution du peuple il
y aura pas de
d'ouvrières manifestants à
Saint-Pétersbourg
mais comme en 1917 mais voilà c'est
Vladimir Poutine sent le danger quand
même un peu autour de lui et c'est pour
ça qu'il est obligé ils se sont obligés
d'agir responsable de la CIA disait
voilà il est comme un requin il faut
qu'il bouge maintenant il faut qu'il
fasse quelque chose pour continuer à
vivre d'ailleurs au passage rendez-vous
qui sera très intéressant c'est celui du
G20
à Bali le 20 novembre la grande question
savoir ce que Vladimir Poutine va y
assister ou pas
sachant que
très probablement et sera tenté de ne
pas y assister par
crainte peut-être de s'éloigner
dangereusement du Kremlin je ferme cette
parenthèse
donc oui Wagner on a parlé
oui
Vladimir Poutine observe toujours enfin
si la guerre était déclenchée c'est en
partie aussi chaque fois que la Russie
fait quelque chose
[Musique]
c'est parce qu'elle estime que il n'y
aura pas forcément de réaction
étrangères mise sur la faiblesse de
l'étranger moi je faisais partie de ceux
qui pensaient que
effectivement Vladimir Poutine
de lancerait pas cette guerre se
lancerait pas dans cette guerre parce
que c'était
c'était pas conforme là l'histoire de
l'emploi de la force en Russie qui était
un emploi qui peut être extrêmement
brutal extrêmement violent mais qui
était relativement prudent
et donc la Russie dans tous la Russie et
l'Union soviétique engagé la force on a
fait des choses que lorsqu'elle estimait
que il y aurait finalement pas de
réaction ou peu de réaction qui a pas de
grand risque de l'étranger à lancer
cette fois une guerre et
là l'invasion de de la Crimée alors il y
avait les événements en l'Ukraine qui
ont précipité les choses la révolution
de Maiden en particulier mais il y avait
aussi derrière il y avait le sentiment
que les États-Unis ne bougeraient pas
que que président Obama est un président
faible
nous on interventionniste que
un événement qui est par exemple a
beaucoup marqué les esprits c'est
c'est le non-respect de la ligne rouge
qui avait été fixé en Syrie lorsque
Obama et nous aussi nous avions dit
voilà usage d'armes chimiques c'est une
ligne rouge qui suscitera des
rétention immédiate
la ligne rouge est franchie il se passe
rien et là c'est un immense à feu de
faiblesse de la part de de la part des
États-Unis et qui est exploité
immédiatement par la Russie qui voilà il
y a toute une série d'enchaînements en
Crimée dans le bon basse l'engagement
lui-même en Syrie
en septembre
2015 etc et là quand Joe Biden dit il y
aura jamais un soldat
américain en Ukraine
[Musique]
je pense c'est à mon sens c'est une
erreur une erreur stratégique il faut
toujours maintenir certains ambiguïté
sur la possibilité de la force mais
c'est d'une certaine façon c'est un feu
vert donné russe sur voilà il y aura
finalement
pas de grandes réaction forte il y aura
des sanctions économiques il y aura
quelque chose mais en fait ça ira pas
très loin et je pense fondamentalement
que Poutine est à
malestimé la situation
la mal estimé les réactions de la de
l'Ukraine déjà
mal estimé des réactions du monde mon
occidental et qui alors pourquoi cette
mauvaise estimation mauvaise information
c'est possible pardon et que il probable
que rétrospectivement
vu les
ce que l'on sait de ce qui s'est passé
de vues de l'état de moins estimations
aussi des capacités de son armée
tout ce qui s'est passé il est probable
que voilà maintenant il se lancerait pas
dans cette guerre qui est qui finalement
lui coûte très cher pour un gain qui est
effectivement assez malgré tout assez
limité pour l'instant on pourrait encore
revendiquer finalement une petite
victoire si la guerre s'est arrêtée
aujourd'hui il pourrait mais à quel prix
que vous prie absolument que colossal et
donc
et donc oui la Russie regarde les
estimations regarde ce que en
particulier les États-Unis a toujours un
effet miroir les Américains les Russes
le regard des États-Unis qui est le
rival qui est la menace qui est en même
temps un peu le miroir en forme de
fascination malgré tout pour pour la
puissance américaine quoi qui est
voilà
c'est vous qui me parlez de la surprise
de valeklia comment les Russes
oui alors c'est voilà donc je rappelle
l'effet nous sommes tout début du mois
de septembre dans la province de kerkiff
et là les les Ukrainiens pour la
première fois réussissent dans cette
guerre réussissent une percée de percée
du Front spectaculaire et tout le
tout le front
russe et disloqué par par l'armée
ukrainienne mais en amont de tout ça il
a fallu effectivement pour les
Ukrainiens concentrer un certain nombre
de forces à proximité à quelques
kilomètres donc vous avez
entre 5 et au moins 5 6 7 brigades une
brigade c'est
ukrainienne c'est entre 3 et 4000 hommes
concentré à quelques kilomètres de la
ligne de front et les Russes n'ont rien
vu ou en tout cas n'ont rien fait pour
ce pas pour parer cette cette attaque
donc oui ça surpris moi j'étais le
premier surprise mais je pensais pas que
ce soit possible de mener une attaque de
cette importance sans être repéré au
passage quoi avec tous les moyens
techniques dont les Russes disposent
depuis les satellites jusqu'au jusqu'au
spetnase les unités vous avez dans
chaque armée russe une actuellement une
à neuf qui sont déployés vous avez une
brigade de spetnase avec des commandos
qui sont infiltrés qui sont censés
observer tout ce qui se passe
sur sur le front vous avez des drones
vous avez de moyens qui normalement font
que il est impossible d'être de leur
d'organiser une opération de grande
envergure sans que on le sache et puis
là oui bon surprise donc est-ce que ces
moyens ont été défaillants
russes c'est moyen de renseignement
russe ont été défaillants est-ce que il
y a eu des renseignements mais qui ont
mal été exploités enfin il y a toutes
quand il y a un désastre c'est que
généralement il y en a un qui est très
bon d'un côté et l'autre qui est très
mauvais de l'autre et là au moins
localement les les forces russes ont été
très mauvaises à la chaîne de
commandement a été très mauvaise dans
son estimation de la situation dans son
appréciation dans l'organisation de la
défense ce qui fait qu'ils ont été
complètement surpris voilà alors après
c'est
voilà mais je peux pas difficilement en
tire plus je suis toujours encore étonné
de de cette de cette situation mais les
Russes sont parfois étonnants
comment ils arrivent à
faire en sorte que le croiseur se
retrouve une zone de vulnérabilité
totale et que il soit pas capable de
parer une attaque une attaque de missile
voilà c'est des choses qui qui
surprennent pourquoi
les choses que je comprends pas toujours
quoi pourquoi les Russes alors c'est en
particulier Wagner d'ailleurs continue à
attaquer la ville de backmut de ces
trois mois qui est s'obstine attaqué la
ville de backmut alors que c'est la plus
aucun sens véritablement militaire cela
pouvait en avoir précédemment c'était
une première étape vers les villes de
cramator ce que slow Bank qui était des
objectifs la conquête du tomba c'était
l'objectif partir du moment cette
conquête n'est plus d'actualité que
c'est même plus possible continuer à
attaquer cette petite ville de bacmut
obstinément tous les jours ou presque
militairement ça aurait été ça pas
énormément de sens donc il y a plein de
choses qui qui me surprennent dans dans
cette armée change de sujet de questions
on leur parler effectivement de
des modèles d'armée et des modèles
du modèle de capital technique d'une
armée un des problèmes que l'on a depuis
longtemps c'est que
les programmes d'équipement chaque
programme d'équipements majeur coûte en
moyenne entre 2 et 3 fois enfin entre 2
et 4 fois même souvent le prix de la
génération précédente qu'il remplace bon
sur la longue durée on s'aperçoit que le
coût des équipements militaires majeurs
il augmente environ de 7% par an
en matière les chartes de bataille par
exemple
statistique sur la charte bataille
américain bah écoute 10% par an de plus
chaque année en moyenne voilà or
évidemment les budgets d'équipements ils
croisent pas de 7% par an quoi donc le
budget de défense d'une manière générale
croise pas de 7 % par donc il y a
forcément un problème et donc il y a
forcément situation de de contraction
qui se fait on ne remplace pas on n'a
pas le même nombre
de d'engins que précédemment etc
les armées
nous avons été plongés dans une grande
crise budgétaire de en haut de la fin de
guerre froide 1990 jusqu'à 2015 en
grande partie parce que
dans les années 80 on a lancé tout un
tas de programmes d'armement l'avion
Rafale porte-avion Charles de Gaulle
l'hélicoptère Tigre etc etc le véhicule
blindé combat d'infanterie même le
Charles Leclerc bon tous ces équipements
conçus dans les années 80 une époque où
le budget où on approchait les 3% ont
été à 2,9% du PIB en
1990 où on était sur voilà sur une
croissance qui était assez régulière bon
on pouvait éventuellement
se les payer
au prix une contraction quand même du
modèle mais le problème qui s'est posé
c'est que on a globalement conservé tous
ces grands programmes en diminuant le
budget voilà donc on a en diminuant
l'effort de défense en tout cas et ce
qui fait que en 2015 on avait notre
budget de la défense représenté à peu
près été en euros constance celui de
1984 et on a conservé ce programme et
donc on se trouve une situation une
contradiction majeure où on avait encore
moins les moyens de se payer c'est ces
nouveaux équipements qu'avant et donc il
y a eu tout un tas de situations on a
retardé ces programmes on les a réduit
certains programmes comme le véhicule le
VBC de l'armée de terre ou les frégates
frame finalement au bout du compte ont
coûté plus cher qu'initialement prévu
mais pour moins d'équipements qui
initialement prévu
etc donc on a conservé aussi des
équipements plus anciens qui au bout du
compte on finit par coûter également
très cher
en maintenance
et comme ça suffisait pas on a commencé
à dire bah voilà on va économiser sur le
budget de fonctionnement et on va
supprimer des dizaines de milliers de
postes qui nous vont permettre de payer
finalement ces grands programmes et
ainsi de suite et on a une sorte de
l'immense contraction
de de notre armée qui fait que
actuellement notre capacité de projeter
notre capacité de constituer de Sion de
nos forces on rappelle que le contrat
opérationnel majeur c'est 15000 hommes
qui doivent être déployés
complètement équipé
voilà une 45 45 avions de de combat en
réalité voilà c'est parce que c'est
c'est tout ce que nous sommes capables
d'équiper alors ils seront équipés de
matériel relativement moderne pas de
problème mais 15000 hommes
1990 on était capable de déployer
j'avais calculé on était capable de
déployer 120 régiment dans l'armée terre
uniquement 120 régiment de combat aux
frontières en l'espace de quelques jours
120 régiment blindé infanterie
hélicoptère de combat active réserve
active appelé professionnel
mais il avait 120 régiment actuellement
voilà coup de sifflet on dit voilà il
faut défendre la frontière combien on
peut déployer combien l'armée de terre
pour être déployer de effectivement
complètement équipé et en quelques jours
peut-être 10 12 15
grand maximum grand maximum donc c'est
le ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
le fait de se concentrer uniquement sur
des grands programmes d'équipements
toujours plus sophistiqué toujours plus
cher abouti mécaniquement à une
contraction des armées parce qu'on n'a
pas les moyens tout simplement de se le
payer
le CPU donc ça aboutit à une armée de
plus en plus réduite alors les engins
que peuvent être très bons mais ils
peuvent pas être partout non plus et
donc oui il faut absolument réfléchir à
une façon de faire un peu différente je
prends l'exemple des drones alors avoir
des engins d'autres très sophistiqués
dans certains domaines clés c'est
essentiel mais
par ailleurs c'est il faut avoir quelque
chose de mixte l'hybride aussi si on
veut parler comme ça quoi avec des
choses qui sont beaucoup plus low cost
l'exemple du drone tb2h c'est un exemple
parfait quoi c'est à dire voilà les
Turcs ont développé un système de drone
armé qui est pas le top de de parce
qu'il se fait de mieux en quelques
années mais voilà c'est suffisant et
surtout il est là nous on attend
toujours notre propre drone armé
là ils ont développé en quelques années
et ils ont quelque chose qui marche bien
qui est relativement peu coûteux donc
c'est si c'est peu coûteux on peut en
fabriquer beaucoup on peut utiliser
massivement et le drone TB2 ils ont
changé la guerre dans la poche dite
libre en Syrie ils ont changé
en Arménie bien sûr ils ont changé la
guerre en Libye ils ont changé la guerre
en Éthiopie et ils ont eu un impact très
important en particulier au début de la
guerre en Ukraine et voilà pourquoi
pourquoi ce n'est pas la France qui est
qui est la qui avait toutes les
possibilités pourquoi la France va pas
développer des engins comme ça ça c'est
une vraie question parce que
oui mais c'est la faute
là il faut se poser les questions sur
sur nos industriels qui pour qui c'est
pas forcément
très à la fois très rentable ni très
prestigieux
les militaires les armées aussi
je prendre un autre exemple mais
il y a quelques années on est des je
crois que c'est pas à l'époque qui avait
développé le projet du crabe le crabe
c'est un engendre reconnaissance
relativement
rustique peu coûteux très efficace mais
quand on l'a présenté ce enfin de
l'armée l'armée de dire le problème
c'est qu'il est pas coûteux
c'est que à une époque où on défendait
les budgets absolument partout en dire
mais attendez si on propose ça on va
dire bah très bien pas toi l'amour
l'adopte mais du coup on va réduire
votre budget
et donc non on pourra dire donc il faut
comme il faut défendre le budget donc on
va proposer des choses qui sont plus
chères etc enfin bon enfin il y a tout
un tas de questions qui se posent sur
comment se fait-il que il a fallu 10 ans
pour changer d'armes de fusil d'assaut
dans notre armée
alors que nos soldat était engagé en
Afghanistan est engagé au combat tous
les jours et il a fallu 10 ans pour
acheter finalement une arme qui était
qui existait déjà qui était sur le
marché et il suffisait de l'acheter il
fallait suffisait de décider de
l'acheter en plus c'était pas un
programme non plus majeur c'est pas
représentait pas des milliards de dos
bon il a fallu 10 ans voilà pourquoi ton
autre exemple
le félin système félin pour le fantassin
bon voilà vous allez dans tous les
régiments d'infanterie vous dites on le
fait là ça marche pas quoi c'est un truc
on a mis 20 ans pour développer ce truc
est devenu une sorte d'usine à gaz
portable
et voilà quelque chose il y a quelques
équipements qui sont intéressants mais
tout le reste voilà c'était mais on a
mis 20 ans donc entre pendant ses 20 ans
n'était pas forcément
reçu pas grand-chose
j'exagère ils ont été équipés mais je
veux dire ça a pris 20 ans ça coûtait
très cher une panoplie c'est plus de 40
000 euros
à l'époque où j'étais voilà j'ai dit si
quand j'étais sergent chef de groupe de
combat d'infanterie on m'a dit tiens on
te donne 40000 euros par soldat et tu te
débrouilles tu achètes ce que tu veux
ben j'aurais eu un groupe de combat
super équipé très bien en achetant sur
étagère ce sont des choses qui
existaient déjà et j'aurais été ravi et
j'aurais eu quelque chose de d'efficace
tout de suite très important tout de
suite donc voilà il faut il faut
vraiment se poser
la question sur la manière dont on
gère nos programmes
gérant le programme d'équipement je
poursuis sinon j'aurais jamais le temps
de répondre à toutes questions sur les
la gestion des blessés j'avoue que j'ai
pas beaucoup de d'éléments là-dessus le
gestion des blessés en l'Ukraine
voilà ce qu'est ce qu'il faut je pense
retenir c'est que d'un seul coup on a
oublié on a oublié la mort en grande
échelle voilà on a oublié la gestion de
qu'il fallait être capable de de gérer
d'un seul coup des milliers de blessés
éventuellement
en même temps
baissé militaire bien sûr mais c'est
civil et je suis pas sûr là aussi il
faut s'interroger sur notre capacité de
leur capacité aussi remonter remonter en
puissance notre
système de santé
et
voilà donc mais j'ai assez peu
d'informations globalement sur sur la
matière sur sur le crâne
sur le renseignement oui bien sûr que le
renseignement américain il est très
important tous les moyens techniques
satellitaires les avions radar c'est
extrêmement important qui vole à
proximité ou les drones de surveillance
qui vole à proximité de la frontière ou
dans les eaux de la Mer Noire c'est
fondamental c'est fondamental parce que
par exemple ça permet de
déceler les tirs de missiles
un missile balistique les missiles
balistiques qui sont lancés ou de
missile de croisière qui sont lancés
contre l'Ukraine ils sont pas tirés en
Ukraine ils sont ils viennent de
Biélorussie ils sont tout autour de en
périphérie de la pilule Russie jusqu'à
la mer Noire ils sont en périphérique
mais pour atteindre leur cible en
Ukraine ils leur faut
5-6 entre 5 et 10 minutes
croisières c'est plus long mais missile
balistique il faut 5 10 minutes pour
arriver sur l'objectif donc il faut
réagir très vite et avec des radars
aériens et seuls les Américains enfin le
mouvement les pays de l'OTAN ont des
radars aériens à proximité et ou des
satellites permettent de déceler tout de
suite les tirs et ça et les Américains
quand ils le peuvent communiquer tous
ces éléments tirs qui permettent à la
défense antiérienne
ukrainienne de s'organiser un peu plus
efficacement mais vous avez également dû
renseignement tactique sur les émissions
tout ce qui les émissions radio et puis
les Russes sont pas très discret en la
matière sont pas très bons donc ça
permet de déceler ils sont assez rigides
aussi les Russes leur organisation du
commandement donc ça permet de déceler
effectivement où sont leur pose de
commandement ça permet éventuellement de
le brouiller de s'introduire genre au
passage la bataille la victoire de
kerkiff
spectaculaire enfin le dislocation du
dispositif russe a permis de récupérer
énormément de matériel russe dont des
équipements de guerre électroniques dont
des radars tout un tas de trucs qui vous
font évidemment le miel de tous les
services j'espère nous aussi mais au
moins américain qui d'un seul coup
énormément de renseignements sur tous
les systèmes de communication de
transmission de détection russe et
évidemment tout ça ça profite aussi
évidemment aux Ukrainiens les Ukrainiens
bénéficient d'une supériorité de
l'information très claire point de vue
tactique qui est un de leurs avantages
alors ça vient aussi de partout ça vient
aussi d'en bas
l'armée ukrainienne c'est l'armée la
plus connectée au monde maintenant c'est
à dire que vous avez d'abord vous avez
plein de gens vous avez plein de
populations civile qui ont des
smartphones qui communiquent grâce
notamment aussi aux réseaux Starlink de
London musk mais ça c'est un vrai atout
stratégique les Russes ont pas été
capables de couper les communications
c'est normalement c'est quelque chose
qu'on essaie de faire en début de début
de conflit on coupe complètement autant
que possible toutes les communications
tous les réseaux puis on paralyse le
commandement là les Russes ont été
incapables de le faire en partie à cause
de de réseaux satellitaire Starlink et
tout ça permet à des gens de communiquer
de donner des informations
vous avez c'est l'armée qui dispose le
plus de drones au monde vous avez des
unités complètes qui sont constituées de
renseignements avec en achetant des
drones civils vous achetez des drones
civils de drones chinois low cost et
voilà une petite caméra bah vous faites
des unités d'enseignement et donc vous
avez
les Ukrainiens ont beaucoup
d'informations tactiques évidemment ça
leur sert énormément qu'en plus vous
coupez ça avec une capacité de frappe à
longue distance précise ça vous donne
des résultats évidemment que très
importants les lance-roquettes là aussi
quelque chose tient voilà que un
instrument qui est
révélé peut-être dans cette guerre aussi
c'est lance-roquette multiple la grande
distance c'est c'est un atout majeur
pour pour les Ukrainiens ou notre
artillerie précise grand distance
coupler ça avec la bonne information ça
a des effets considérables parmi ça me
fait penser voilà parmi aussi des
révélateurs tactiques un peu de de
cette guerre c'est tout ce qu'on appelle
l'artillerie par la fin l'armement en
T-shirt par le haut c'est-à-dire que les
Ukrainiens sont également l'infanterie
ukrainienne et celle qui est la me dotée
au monde en armement anti-charles
maintenant et parmi ces armements
antichard vous avez cette capacité à
frapper par le haut voilà missile
Jablines les Enzo
britannique pourquoi par le haut parce
que ou même frapper par les drones TB2
parce que c'est là où les les chars ou
les véhicules blindés sont le plus
vulnérables et donc les véhicules
blindés russes ils se sont protégés de
partout ils sont hyper blindés devant
mais par le haut ils sont très
vulnérables donc dans le premier mois de
guerre dans le premier mois de guerre
vous avez à peu près un millier de
véhicules de combat majeurs qui ont été
perdus par les Russes trois à peu près
au moins 400 400 chars russes Charentes
bataille qui ont été perdus par les
Russes je rappelle que nous on a à peu
près 200 250
mais ceux qui ont été ceux qui ont été
détruits ont été détruits par le haut en
grande partie
par le haut par l'eau par les toits
grâce à cette tout cette et là
pour l'instant on n'a pas beaucoup de
parades à cette ces éléments on y
réfléchit mais il y a pas beaucoup de
paradis je oui
oui je sais bien je sais bien
oui alors sur la stratégie russe
d'attaque des des villes oui c'est
clairement une stratégie par défaut
effectivement
et ça revient à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur la campagne des missiles V1
V2 allemands sur sur les villes d'Europe
occidentale c'est on fait ça parce que
on sait pas quoi faire d'autre en
réalité il y a pas beaucoup d'autres
marges de manœuvre et en espérant que ça
va faire craquer la population
ce type de stratégie historiquement n'a
jamais fonctionné jamais une population
n'a
craqué sous sous la pression sous le
bombardements voilà moi j'étais rappelé
monsieur président j'étais engagé à
Sarajevo ça il y avait 200 exactement
une moyenne de 253 obus qui tombaient
chaque jour sur la ville
ça pendant trois ans plus les slipers
plus ton tas de choses et bon voilà ça
jamais craquer la population les seuls
les seules situations historiques ou des
populations se sont révélées et ont
imposé un changement de politique
vraiment leur gouvernement c'est oui ces
populations qui étaient sous pression sa
population russe 1917 c'est la
population allemande 1918 voilà là il y
a eu un vrai impact mais c'était une
combinaison certainement de pression sur
cette population incontestablement mais
surtout ça s'accompagnait de défaites
militaires
voilà c'est cette combinaison des deux
qui fait
qui va faire qui peut avoir un effet
stratégique sinon les
Ukrainiens qui ont connu aussi les
Ukrainiens ont connu des années 90
période de crise
il y avait pas d'électricité non plus et
ils étaient avec des bougies et
résisteront à cette campagne même si
c'est même si c'est difficile et ça
n'aura pas de défait
mais côté russe il faut montrer voilà
qu'on fait quelque chose y compris le
montrer à sa population
on parlait d'un vétusté des armements
les drones oui les drones Iraniens qui
se sont sensiblement les mêmes qui ont
été utilisés je pense en Arabie Saoudite
donc
bon je vais pas plus loin pas
oui oui non mais il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de questions sur
Oui la couche spatiale effectivement
c'est aussi ça fait partie de
des choses des vulnérabilités
par le traité de 1967 qui
indique qu'il s'agit d'un territoire qui
n'appartient en personne c'est-à-dire
c'est comme la haute mer
donc ça apertit à personne mais les
objets qui se trouvent appartiennent à
des nations et donc les attaquer c'est
attaquer directement les nations
mais ça peut dans la mesure où on est
devenu extrêmement dépendant quand même
de l'espace il faut
à la fois concevoir malgré tout le
combat dans cette dans cette dans cette
région et surtout imaginer se préparer
la situation où il y a plus de liaisons
alternes par exemple voilà c'est quelque
chose sur lequel il faut se préparer
anticiper que ce soit dans les armées ou
dans la société vous avez un roman de
science-fiction qui s'appelle spin où on
imagine justement ça il y a une bulle
qui se met autour de la Terre et qui
coupe toutes les liaisons satellites
voilà et donc
il faudra apprendre à vivre sans sans
satellite tout s'arrête là oui et puis
personne ah oui oui bien sûr mais il
faut il faut quand même un peu
l'anticiper quoi
[Musique]
oui alors je
pourquoi pourquoi
aider l'Ukraine
pourquoi aider l'Ukraine c'est une
vision d'abord politique c'est pas
non mais tu rappelles que nous avons
fait la guerre à l'Irak parce que l'Irak
avait envahi le Koweït que c'était une
voilà hormis
au pied toutes les règles du droit
international tous les mécanismes du
droit international là on a quand même
une puissance qui appartient en plus au
Conseil de sécurité qui est et qui
[Musique]
fait fille complètement de ce droit qui
agresse un pays
aucune raison valable d'agresser un pays
voisin de l'envahir et accessoirement de
s'y comporter de la manière dont dans
les sols c'est si comporte voilà on peut
d'autres exemples effectivement de pays
qui full le droit dans le monde bien sûr
maintenant voilà je pense que
on a raison d'aider l'Ukraine que la
réalité je pense que là c'est la Russie
qui nous a déclaré la confrontation je
rappelle renvoie au discours
au discours même de Vladimir Poutine
encore du 30 septembre ou encore très
récemment
cet homme là nous déteste
des tests et nous a déclaré une forme de
guerre parce que on n'est pas nous
sommes entre puissance du nucléaire nous
sommes entre gens en puissance doté et
que c'est compliqué mais on a quelque
chose qui ressemble quand même très
largement à un contexte de guerre froide
de la guerre froide le discours de
Vladimir Poutine pourrait être aurait pu
être un discours de l'époque de l'Union
soviétique se plaçant à la tête d'un
camp anti impérialiste contre voilà
contre les puissances occidentales
décadentes voilà la différence c'est que
l'Union soviétique pouvait
éventuellement proposer un modèle qui
pourrait être séduisant qui était
peut-être nouveau enfin progressiste
certaines façons et alors que bon le
modèle russe est pas forcément
extraordinairement attractif quand même
voilà c'est un peu la différence est
passé quelque chose qui est un discours
qui est quand même assez plutôt
réactionnaire et qui et qui nous menace
c'est encore une fois je pense que
je pense que sont c'est la Russie qui
déclenchait les hostilités à notre égard
la première depuis plusieurs années déjà
et que elle fout le pied les le droit
international et que on peut pas laisser
on peut pas voilà on peut pas laisser
passer ça mais encore une fois c'est une
décision très largement politique qui
aurait peut-être mérité effectivement
d'être peut-être plus expliqué expliquer
peut-être plus clairement peut-être que
le Parlement aussi voilà
s'exprimer également sur les questions
ou voter oui non mais demain non non il
faut pas mais voilà mais il faut dans
tous les cas de figure bien sûr il faut
expliquer aux gens pourquoi et
pourquoi on fait au bout du compte des
sacrifices parce que ça forcément un
impact sur au moins sur notre vie
courante et ça pourquoi on fait ça tout
simplement
voilà je sais plus du tout où j'en suis
on parlait des corridors de la bataille
des céréales
[Musique]
oui alors les Russes ont pris le
prétexte de l'attaque de Sébastopol donc
le 29 octobre dernier
au passage une attaque
par drone encore une fois on y revient
c'est tac un peu de type nouveau même si
les Iraniens ont fait la même chose en
péninsule arbitre mais là on a une
attaque de
un bombardement par drone
aérien navale sur une base importante
qui a touché au moins et un navire
important une frégate
donc c'est un coup assez dur qui est
porté
à la flotte un nouveau coup porté la
flotte on parlait de l'espace aérien
mais on pourrait parler aussi
effectivement de l'espace maritime de
voilà on a quand même un pays qui avec
la flotte de la mer Noire qui a une
flotte puissante et qui finalement se
retrouve en train de
subir des coups et d'en train de se
replier cette flotte et de se repli de
plus en plus un nouveau récit ce que sur
dans le Caucase alors que
j'ai tenu en échec appelle des armes un
peu anti-axé des missiles dont inavir
tout un tas de choses qui font qui
rendent aussi de la même façon que toute
cette missilerie antiérienne rend le
ciel très dangereux pour pour les avions
ou des hélicoptères la mère devient au
moins aux abords des côtes devient
extrêmement dangereuse pour pour des
navires d'un vire extrêmement coûteux là
aussi qui peuvent être coulés par
toucher par quelques missiles ou
maintenant par des drones donc ça c'est
vraiment au passage d'un point de vue
politique ce qui est intéressant aussi
dans ces attaques sur la Crimée je pense
d'un point de vue
ukrainien c'est que
prépare l'idée
de
comment dire ils amènent la bataille sur
le sol primaire la Crimée c'est très
particulier effectivement on se pose
beaucoup de questions autant le don de
basse ok maintenant c'est officiellement
enfin les Russes l'ont annexé si elles
ont planté le drapeau mais en réalité
bon voilà personne n'est dupe c'est
quand même pas voilà c'est pas pas la
Russie la Crimée c'est différent la
Crimée là il y avait un attachement qui
est beaucoup plus important à ce
territoire pour les gens stratégique
pour les raisons historiques etc et le
territoire lui-même globalement se sent
beaucoup plus russe que que les
territoires qui viennent d'annexer
et là ces attaques sur la Crimée il y a
eu l'attaque de la base de Saki il y a
eu d'autres attaques même la taxe sur le
bancaire je pense que ça contribue aussi
à
banaliser la guerre en Crimée et cette
idée on appelait ça pendant la guerre
froide la stratégie de l'artichaut c'est
à dire qu'on petit à petit on fait la
guerre en endroit qui normalement de
doit être sanctuarisé et puis finalement
au bout d'un moment
il y a la guerre il y a la guerre en
Crimée donc peut-être que en bataillon
qui va débarquer en Crimée etc et voilà
est-ce que les Russes dont on dit qu'il
toucheraient qui réagirait de manière
extrêmement violente en Crimée en
réalité pour l'instant alors il
réagissent effectivement c'est à partir
de cette attaque ils ont lancé ils ont
augmenté les doses de missiles sur sur
l'Ukraine et puis ils ont dénoncé
en prétextant cette attaque ils ont
dénoncé l'accord sur le sur les céréales
bon
on ne sait pas actuellement où ils en
sont alors
je pense pour ma part que ils vont
revenir termineration ils ont intérêt
aussi c'était un des rares endroits où
on avait pu se mettre d'accord enfin
voilà où il y a plus y avoir un accord
entre crânien et russe dans cette guerre
les Russes y ont également intérêts
alors peut-être qu'ils jouent là dessus
parce que pour essayer d'éliminer un
certain nombre de contraintes qui se
posent sur leur également l'emploi de
leur navire céréalier sur la sortie bon
voilà je pense que on est dans le champ
diplomatique la Turquie qui joue en rôle
majeur dans cette
dans cette crise
va dénouer les choses je pense que on va
revenir quand même à l'accord c'est
rallier mais cette pression cette
embargo sur le serrage c'est une manière
effectivement pour le Russe la Russie de
mondialiser un peu ce conflit ça
contribue à cette voilà un impact sur la
confrontation mondiale voilà c'est une
arme comme les autres qui est utilisée
par la Russie vraiment demandé de
synthétiser parce que j'ai on a quand
même un dossier
je
ne sais plus en parler voilà un dernier
mois peut-être le dernier mot sur sur
les réserves effectivement sur
l'organisation des réserves
et ce sera une des premières décisions
s'il était ministre désormais
non mais ce serait intéressant que dans
votre conclusion vous nous disiez et
parce que là ça concerne directement la
Commission les trois ou quatre principes
idées des dossiers importants qu'on doit
retrouver dans la LPM si vous voulez
quelle tenue du constat que vous faites
qu'est-ce qu'il faut absolument que l'on
inscrit dans l'alpm je crois que ce
qu'il faut un élément majeurs c'est
la capacité à remonter en puissance
voilà il faut que face à une surprise
stratégique face à quelque chose de
nouveau où il faut changer d'échelle on
soit capable de le faire et donc ça ça
pose forcément le problème de on peut
pas le faire sans faire appel ressources
de la nation d'un seul coup et tout ça
ça s'organise donc sur des réserves des
réserves matérielles des stocks des
choses comme ça des réserves humaines
tout ça ça s'organise donc je pense
qu'il faut déjà avoir une structure de
commandement avoir quelque chose ça se
planifie ça s'improvise pas quoi on voit
bien d'ailleurs ce qui se passe en
Russie dans la mobilisation des réserves
lorsque c'est fait de manière improvisée
il y a rien de prévu donc ça s'organise
ça c'est première chose être capable de
remonter en puissance très vite
deuxième chose
je sais plus où j'ai été mais
oui il faut là aussi
être capable de
[Musique]
réfléchir à ce qu'on dit tout à l'heure
sur la sur notre politique c'est
vraiment notre politique d'équipement on
va dire comme ça sur voilà il faut
réfléchir à une manière d'avoir des
choses plus rapides
peut-être pas peut-être plus éphémère
après tout mais plus rapide
moins coûteuse
et plus adapté peut-être immédiatement
adaptable donc il faut gagner de la
souplesse on va dire comme ça il faut
peut-être imiter la manière dont les
Américains ont fonctionné pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale donc ils étaient
capables de développer très rapidement
des des équipements militaires
suffisants efficaces beaucoup d'eux
qu'on peut fabriquer en grande quantité
pour l'instant
c'est des engins excessivement
sophistiqués qui coûte très cher mais
voilà non mais hélicoptères c'est la
même poésie que parce qu'il faut c'est
peut-être mon dernier point c'est que il
faut sortir de cette logique de corps
expéditionnaire limité dans lequel on se
trouvait c'est-à-dire être capable de
mener des petites opérations qui étaient
suffisantes
appuyé par une industrie qui était près
de l'industrie qui est de l'artisanat en
réalité
on fait de l'artisanat de luxe
quand on produit un canon tous les 18
mois c'est heureusement qu'en 1914 on
disait pas un canon tous les dions sinon
on aurait perdu la guerre mais on fait
de l'artisanat de luxe voilà donc c'est
pour les industriels c'est peut-être
très profitable mais voilà c'est pas
adapté la situation il faut réfléchir
voilà
à une manière de d'avoir des choses
beaucoup plus rapidement plus efficaces
et je prends l'exemple d'une dernière
fois l'exemple de drone TB2 turc voilà
quelque chose voilà ce
accessoirement plus beaucoup plus
exportable au lieu de se contenter
d'avoir des clients riches
et puis africains ne peuvent pas se
payer tout voilà donc du coup on trouve
des équipements russes en Afrique et
donc ce qui contribue aussi à la
politique d'influence par ailleurs bon
donc oui repenser notre notre politique
de d'équipement et puis le troisième
élément c'est repenser
l'emploi de nos forces dans le cadre
d'une confrontation être capable de
projeter de l'aide être capable de
projeter des forces être mais notamment
être capable de d'agir dans
tous les champs de la confrontation mais
ça ça se pense ça aussi ça se réfléchit
ça s'organise
et
voilà donc être réfléchir l'emploi de
d'action l'action clandestine sur
confrontation qu'on l'a perdu c'est la
confrontation des années 80 contre Lyon
on l'a perdu parce que l'Iran nous
attaquer dans le champ clandestin
des attentats des enlèvements des
attentats à Paris des attaques au Liban
etc et on a été incapable de de répondre
à ça dans ce domaine donc il faut et
voilà ça fait partie de du monde qui est
globalement plus dangereux et puis
dernier élément c'est qu'il faut penser
que en 2035 tout ça va changer
et il faut anticiper le fait que un jour
les choses changeront forcément beaucoup
et ça revient du certaines façons à
cette idée d'avoir une certaine
souplesse et d'avoir des des réserves
des réserves d'hommes d'équipement
d'idées aussi
qui seront indispensables pour faire
face aux défis futures merci mon colonel
merci de tous ces éléments très très
riches qui qui nous éclaire
effectivement non seulement sur la
situation mais
sur ce que nous devons faire moi je
retiens effectivement cet élément de la
réserve et puis cette nécessité
d'adaptabilité permanente parce que les
Russes aussi s'adapteront enfin je
dirais tireront dans 10 ans dans 15 ans
les leçons de ce qu'il leur arrive
les sujets pour la Russie reviennent
constamment c'est à dire cette volonté
de détendre en permanence
donc bien merci infiniment mon colonel
j'invite nos collègues à suivre sur
Twitter votre
notre site qui s'appelle la voix de
l'épée vous apprendrez beaucoup de
choses sur ce qui a été évoqué ce matin
merci infiniment